foreign
[Music]
us the Circuit Court of Fairfax county
is now in session John will pay asteroid
resigned please
good morning
all right do we have any preliminary
matters before the jury comes out
thank you
okay
good morning
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
tomorrow
[Applause]
cylinder oath okay
all right next question thank you
Amber when did the first Act of physical
violence by Mr Depp occur which I
shouldn't asked and answered
no overwhelmed good
that would have been early 2012. and how
did you determine this
I reviewed my therapy objection hearsay
I I she hasn't even answered it all
right I'll allow the answer
by reviewing my therapist notes
objection I'll sustain the objection
but it's not offered to prove the truth
of the matter asserted it's it's
explaining what she looked at I'll
sustain the objection okay
um
when did you earlier believe the First
Act of physical violence occurred
well I had
always believed up until recently that
it was it had started later that the
violence started around early 2013 not
early 2012.
no you testified earlier that the First
Act of physical violence by Mr Depp
related to the Winona wino tattoo do you
recall that testimony I do okay is that
does that change your testimony
realizing that this was earlier was this
in fact still this is the First Act
objection leading
uh sustained
what was what was the first act
objection asked and answered sustained
how do you remember the first act of
violence
uh well you never forget it that's how I
remember it it changes your life forever
you never forget the first time someone
hits you like that
I just had the date wrong
okay and how did how is it that you
think you got the date wrong
objection culture speculation overruled
um
I'm embarrassed to say I think I would
have liked to have believed that the
period of time
in which I had to fall in love with
Johnny in which we fell in love and he
was sober
and he wasn't violent to me lasted for a
lot longer than it did
I think I would have liked to have
believed that
I
I wasn't hit so early in the
relationship and still stayed he was
also sober for a period in 2012 which
was a peaceful Time For Us in which we
fell in love so I had kind of allowed
myself I guess to forget that the
beginning of that period 2012 before he
got sober was was really violent and
chaotic as well
I I'm embarrassed to say that
now you testified that the police were
called multiple times other than the May
21 2016 what other occasions were there
where the police were called
they were called in December of 2011.
they were called in 2012.
uh they were called uh in 2013 in March
by the landlord
they I had sought advice from Laurel
Anderson as to whether I should call the
police objection hearsay sustain
okay
when you filed the domestic violence
temporary restraining order how many
acts of abuse did you allege at that
time
I gave the last couple I believe last
two incidents maybe three and why didn't
you tell all the acts of abuse at that
time
I was following advice from my counsel
okay how many instances of abuse were
included in the UK trial
there were 14 acts of physical abuse and
violence and three acts of sexual abuse
and why were those 17 included in the UK
trial
well I was not a party
um a direct party I was a witness so it
was whatever their Council the sun
Council chose
when is the
Pond to provide a detailed accounting of
as many times as you could recall of
physical and sexual abuse by Mr Depp
objection hearsay
I don't that's not hearsay your honor
I'm asking her when she was called upon
to do so well the objection is hearsay
right but it's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter asserted and it's
just asking for date
all right over room thank you
uh a few months ago February in
2022 for this year
um was the first time I was asked to to
do so other than a cold in a deposition
okay and when you were asked to provide
those what did you do to be able to
prepare that accounting that full
accounting
well I had the benefit of my therapist
objection hearsay so uh you're under
she's not saying what the therapist said
I'm just asking how overruled objective
thank you go ahead I looked at my
therapist not said the benefit of those
notes which we had received in February
uh as well as I reviewed calendars
photos text messages my journals my
Diaries of which there were many I put
all of those together it took a lot of
time to be able to you know adequately
refresh my recollection and fill in the
details over the course of the five
years we were together
and what did you do when you put that
all together
I
I kind of
filled in uh and collected all of these
various pieces of information
and gave a fuller account as best I
could for each incidence of violence
that I had record of I think it was
called an interrogatory
in this case in this case all right
excuse me did you sign that under oath I
did okay and it was provided to council
for Mr Depp it was okay uh and was it a
pretty lengthy document
it was far too long
and how is it that you didn't just
remember all of those events like this
that's that's
not how
your memory or my memory works you know
we were together for five years almost
four and a half
and uh it was a very violent chaotic at
times very loving emotional
uh uh relationship so as
as anyone can imagine there was a lot
going on and uh unfortunately the
violence became
almost normal
especially towards the end it was just
it's hard to even it's hard to say that
now but the violence was almost normal
and
you know your brain does with trauma
what it does puts it away best you can
so I was
I was um
frankly I was shocked to see
um
a lot of the information presented to me
through my therapist notes because she
was taking a objection your honor
hearsay all right let's just say another
objection okay we'll move past that
there what the therapist said in her
notes okay now there's one more you also
provided a declaration in this case
early on do you recall that trying to
move the case to California yes there
was a declaration in 2019. all right and
did you describe some of the events of
violence in that declaration objection
leading uh what if anything was said
about violent acts in that declaration
I was taking the advice of my Council we
had um it was to get it moved I believe
was there
to include all of them no objection
leading modeled thank you no I did not
include all of the incidents of violence
that was not the point of making this
declaration
we were making this declaration an
effort to move it to California because
as hard as it is to go through this sort
of trial
um as it is it's even harder to do so in
a place that neither Johnny nor I are
connected to
now you testified earlier about guitars
and you said you've never played a
guitar have you ever played a guitar
player in a movie
you could say I posed with a guitar I
turns out I am an unteachable
I'm I'm going to take you to the tape
recordings why did you and Mr Depp start
taping each other
well at first it was not at first it was
meant to be a a way to get to the heart
of our some of our communication issues
uh in order to do
to discover in a therapeutic fashion
kind of what was
some of our issues in our communication
okay now we heard an audio tape earlier
during this trial in which you said the
word couch
repeatedly can you please explain to the
jury what that meant
yes
um
couch was a word that we had been given
that we decided upon rather objection
hearsay
just tell me what tell us what Mr Depp
said about this uh that it was a safe
word it was meant to be a safe word like
a word uh like truce where you put down
the proverbial guns and you say truce
we're not fighting anymore couch was
supposed to be a word that you used that
we used as a truce I don't want to fight
anymore you win let's let's stop this
that was the mention of couch which you
heard earlier in a recording
now what if any discussions did you have
with Mr Depp about
threatening to divorce each other or
threatening to leave objection calls for
hearsay to the extent it calls for
misheard statements I'm asking for
discussions with Mr Depp it's still her
just tell us what Mr debb said don't
tell us what you said
can you repeat the question yeah yeah so
what did Mr Deb say in your discussions
about the use of the term threatening to
divorce or threatening to leave each
other objection leading overrule
uh well Johnny would always say the only
way out of this was death but in fights
in in particularly heated ones uh we had
found you know we were using divorce in
the fight
um in some of our heated fights uh we
tried not to but that kind of
deteriorated after the December incident
that I got beat up pretty badly and and
after that point it was used a lot more
often
now
March 26 2015. this is after the US
first Australian trip and after the
staircase incident I'm going to ask
Michelle can you bring up Depp exhibit
371 a this is a tape recording and it's
going to be at
one minute
one colon zero one to two colon two nine
could you say that times again yes it's
uh one colon zero one two two colon two
nine and if we could I don't know
whether you had turned up that volume I
know it was hard to hear these is this
an Evidence already
um this I'm moving it into evidence your
honor but these are the tape recordings
between the two which I think we had
agreed is there any objection of 371 a
your honor if you just give me a moment
to confirm there's no other voices
please
it's not an Evidence your honor so could
you please confirm that there are no
other voices this is I will confirm that
and it's depths exhibit right Mr deps
371a then any objection no objection
371a in evidence
thank you
we may need
Sammy if I could just if you listen and
we may need to turn that volume up
sometimes your control is a little bit
better than what we have Max
I see somebody who's changing oils
to different versions
of a person that I recognize for a great
moment and then he's absolutely
and he disappears
and then I get a different version of
him and get the insecure scared version
of him
that lashes out
in a different medium every time
so if it's Adderall junky Johnny then
he's abusive and he's the time it leaves
me he's reactionary and
and anything I do inside
is
for violence or anger if I speak to him
honestly blunt me from the heart I'm
yelling at him
If I argue back with him then I'm
abusive
if I don't say anything then I am
a dismissive or absent or it's wrong or
someone else if I engage with him
part of the problem
because if I look at him the wrong way
here's a problem
if I say the wrong thing God knows what
it is
that's the guy who's on a bunch of
[ __ ] speed
what did you mean when you were saying
that to Mr death
that
no matter my perception was that no
matter what I did
no matter what I did to de-escalate walk
away from him to confront him to try to
nothing I did made a difference nothing
I did changed his rage at me nothing I
did changed the violence towards me
nothing I did calmed him down
and I was constantly doing a juggling
Act of what kind of version of Johnny I
was dealing with
there were different versions of him and
they were drastically different from one
another and even more so than them being
different from one another they didn't
even sometimes remember
what the other version did or said they
acted almost like independent versions
of this person depending on what
combination of drugs and alcohol he was
on
that's what I was trying to express to
him it's just the futility of me
responding and successfully in the
futility of trying to constantly
negotiate with him uh
and the substances he was on at the time
I'm going to take you to April
April 10 2015. the premiere of when I
live my life over again uh what if
anything did you do for that premiere
I believe that Premiere was in New York
City it was a small independent film I I
shot I went back to New York to attend
the premiere Michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 421 please
does this accurately depict the scene
portrayed in this picture
yes your honor I'm going to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 421 any
objection no objection all right 421 in
evidence may we publisher thank you
Amber could you please describe for the
jury what this picture is
uh that is a picture of me a few months
I believe this is April of 2015 so it's
a few months after
the March incident that happened in
Australia uh early yeah early March in
which
uh Johnny held me down on the
countertops and my arms were cut on the
glass
um
and in that attack and if we could draw
attention to your arm there are those
scars the what what are those please
describe for the jury what those are
those are scars that I obtained while
Johnny was strangling me and assaulting
me on the countertop in Australia
Michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 423 please
and does this accurately portray the
scene so
yes that's uh hold on a second I'm going
to move the admission of defendants 423
please
no objection 423 in Evans thank you may
republish
all right and please subscribe to the
jury what this shows
uh it is a picture of me on a red carpet
um you can see my scars
um even though I have makeup on them
they're a bit harder to cover
because they're rather fresh
now after this in April of 2015 you
returned to Australia with Mr Deb did
you not
objection leading
overruled I love it thank you uh yes we
did okay and and
tell the jury about that trip
well after
Johnny was able to get
clean off of the Coke and the other
drugs enough to get the hand surgery he
needed there commenced a period of time
of sobriety for Johnny he uh
his doctor had fired him and then came
on when Johnny agreed to get clean
objection hearsay non-responsive
don't say what I mean we've already had
we've already had the testimony from Dr
Kipper but don't say what Dr Cooper did
just just tell the other part just don't
say what somebody else said so there was
this period of sobriety after that and
Johnny was very committed to being clean
and sober and
I thought
we had finally done it we finally did it
we were through it and we were never
going back meaning it was he was going
to be clean and sober for good this time
and we had a wonderful period of
you know it fell back in love or deeper
in love than we were before it seemed if
things were so good we were talking
about a future again we were talking
about having kids I mean when Johnny
wasn't using it was so peaceful we had
such a nut we had a good time together
we went back to Australia like that in
that state and had a few months we even
had my parents come and visit us in
Australia and we were talking about
babies and about buying a farm and you
know looking for homes in California and
we were in a really beautiful peaceful
period it was wonderful
it was wonderful
no how did you did you stay at the same
place that you did the earlier time in
Australia we went back to a very
remodeled
version of that home I mean remodeled
very cleaned up version of that home
uh same walls same structure but looked
a bit different as you can imagine how
did you feel going back to that home
given what had
[Music]
you know the
the home
the home isn't the problem
you know you're if you're living
in domestic violence you don't just not
go home you know you don't just not go
into the kitchen just because you were
slapped in that kitchen people living in
domestic violence live in their homes
it's that's almost
you know the home isn't the problem
that's the normal part of your home and
for me
you know Johnny was my home
where we were a couple was my home
um and that home was often really
violent but it wasn't the structure
itself it was Johnny
and when we went back to Australia got
home Johnny was in a a completely
different you know he had done a
complete 180 clean sober present calm we
were peaceful I mean
any of the the grapes and the problems
that he seemed to have about me
um went away when he was sober
and so we had a really we we managed to
go back to that same house
but in a very different way it felt very
different
June 16 2015
for that tour
while I was in Australia I got the call
for that press store and went to Europe
for the Press tour for that movie
and
um
you know I was nervous because problems
arise when I'm having to work when I
leave objection non-responsive
just any objection next question
Michelle can you please bring up
defendants exhibit 447
I'm going to ask you first does this
accurately portray the scene depicted
yes here and I'm going to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 447 no
objection 447 in evidence you can
publish
thank you and Michelle if you could zoom
in just a little bit closer
Amber could you tell the jury about this
picture
uh yes that's me on the red carpet
promoting the Magic Mike movie I was in
um you can see the scars on my body on
my arms
you can't see
everything of course but okay
okay and Michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 449
and Amber does this
accurately depict the scene portrayed
uh yes it does your honor I'm going to
move the admission of defendants 449 no
objection right 449 in evidence okay
Amber could you please describe to the
jury what this portrays
uh this is uh you can see the scars on
my arm from that attack
uh also around
this time
um
Johnny was calling me on the on the
phone before and after you know while I
was doing these press events and
sometimes I would be on the phone with
him
um kind of managing
accusations about why I didn't pick up
sooner didn't text back sooner and
sometimes I actually on this tour many
times had to delay getting out of the
car or objection non-responsive
I I'll I'll ask that how did Mr Depp
react to your going on this press tour
uh he he was very upset with me I just
remember crying on the phone with him a
lot and having to hang up to do do press
events
thank you
now I'm going to take you to the
southeast Asia train trip that was your
honeymoon trip correct yes it was okay
and that was
July 25 2015.
yes it was okay Michelle I'm going to
ask you to bring up plaintiff's exhibit
162. it's already into evidence
now Mr mcgivern testified that he took
this picture in July of 2013. would you
agree objection mistakes prior testimony
exactly what he testified to
it wasn't I have the transcript
I don't know go ahead it's Mr mcconnelly
is that is that correct
uh I believe I I believe Malcolm Conley
took this on on the Eastern I mean on
the Orient Express Malcolm Connolly not
Travis mcgivern I believe it was Malcolm
on that trip with us yes okay and was it
in 2013 or was it 2015. it was in 2015.
okay July and
please describe if you can what
transpired during this trip
well the uh
the train trip itself uh was
was peaceful
um up until Johnny wanted to start
drinking Brown alcohol he had already
started drinking champagne when I
returned from the Press tour that's what
he was he was drinking wine and
champagne
um
and
um
when I when he wrapped on Pirates five
the plan was for us to do this honeymoon
I you know I was walking a bit on
eggshells because I know a pattern but I
was not wanting to accept that it was
that we had gone back
um to a pattern at all and so we were on
this train uh and on the last night we
were on the train
um after this was taken this photo
um Johnny and I got in an argument about
him wanting to be
allowed meaning wanting him him wanting
me to agree to him drinking liquor uh
and being okay with it
and an argument
followed that in the um in our in our
sleeping car
uh Johnny slapped me across the face and
held me up by the kind of got a hold of
my neck and pushed me up against the
wall of the car
it was a small and narrow Sleeper Car
and there were two beds one on each side
he had me up against the wall while he
was standing on the floor in between the
beds and I was on the bed kind of half
kneeling half standing trying to get his
arms off my neck and he was squeezing my
neck against the real white car for what
felt like
a very long time and every time he kind
of would pull me away from the side of
the car he'd slam me up again my sign me
up against the wall and I remember
looking down at him and trying to get
his arms
off of my neck and I remember thinking
that
he could
he could not even mean to kill me you
know I remember being scared that he
wouldn't even mean to do it and kind of
looking down at him because I was a
slightly above him uh as he was standing
on on the ground
and um kind of clawing at him trying to
get him to you know his arms away from
my neck
um I remember I had um at one point he
ripped the top of my shirt I don't
really remember what it was but I
remember in a breast exposed
at some point I pulled his lapel of his
shirt and he rips the shirt off
of him and wraps it around my neck
and um
that's how I woke up the next morning
actually I woke up with it still around
my neck
and with a giant knot in the back of my
head
did you keep a diary at that time yes I
did Michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 461
objection hearsay
uh it is a diary your honor and I will
just ask her some questions about it
rather than trying to admit it into
evidence at this point right um I'll
wait for the question go ahead what if
uh anything do you recall about
recording what transpired on that train
objection here say I'm just asking her
whether she did I'm not asking what she
recorded all right I'll go ahead
overruled
foreign
I wrote about what happened that night
the next morning
thank you now was did Mr debb suffer any
injuries on that trip
not that I saw I have a lot of pictures
from that trip and he's uninjured
thank you we can take that dog Michelle
thank you
now I'm going to keep you in July of
2015 and Michelle I'm going to ask you
to bring up Depp exhibit 390 a it's a
recording
and I'm going to be asking about from 3
colon 30. to 4 colon 12.
I'm going to move the admission your
honor that's another recording between
Mr Depp and Ms heard there's nobody else
it's plaintiffs what number was it it's
plaintiffs it's uh 390a okay any
objection of 390 a
um
I'm sorry
may we approach okay
foreign
when you said to me that you didn't feel
like you were told when I was recording
you so please stop please stop
please stop [ __ ] acknowledge what I'm
saying before you keep making commands
you are not a screen teacher shut the
[ __ ] up listen to me and then you can
[ __ ] respond understand
you ain't nobody's [ __ ] mom you ain't
no school teacher don't [ __ ] pretend
to be authoritative with me okay fine
you don't exist
what were you discussing in that call
we were discussing uh whether or not
it was all right
to record each other without the other's
permission
and Johnny said it didn't matter anymore
the requirement of of that permission
from me I was trying to say hey
we agreed okay
let's go to August 2015. please describe
your relationship with Mr Depp in that
time frame
you said August August 2015.
uh August
2015 was a very difficult time following
the brief honeymoon we had uh
uh
Johnny's use continued well it started
again is a better way to describe it and
Laura hold so did our disagreements uh
coincidentally non-quits not
coincidentally
um I got an offer to do a job which was
already a problem
or problematic
um I was considering working on a TV
series
that had James Franco in it I was asked
if I would meet with the people who are
making the show objection hearsay it's
not offered to prove the truth of the
matter overrule thank you
and so I was considering taking that job
and it there was a possibility it would
require brief nudity
um which I knew I would have to
negotiate down but uh obviously that was
a problem for Johnny didn't want me to
do that didn't want me to work
and um and and frankly I needed to and
uh there was another film I had coming
out that I had previously shot it's
called London Fields
it was a source of a lot of fighting
between us because of the sexuality in
the role of the constant negotiation
between myself and the filmmakers they
made a film
and Johnny hurt told me that he had
heard about it was unhappy with some of
what he had heard he was unhappy with me
having done a sex scene in it that he
claimed I didn't tell him about
I did not actually film the scene he was
speaking of he demanded that we watched
the a screener of it which is a like a
a version of the film before it's
released we got one sent to where we
were at the time Johnny Chateau in
France it's in a remote part of France
and once again we're in this remote
place and we're screening this film that
I appeared in and there was a scene a
sex scene in that movie
that started before
um
Johnny freaked out uh because it it
looked like me it they had used a body
double
uh unbeknownst to me without my
permission they used a body double to do
a sex scene
so I have an incredibly jealous man who
already is upset with me for breaking
the rule that I had a sex scene on top
of that I'm telling him it wasn't me I
didn't shoot that scene
and you can imagine
how upset he was it was um irate and was
calling me a liar a [ __ ] among other
things and we had this
that combined with the fact that I had
even entertained doing this job that
involved James Franco was a a pressure
cooker
I called it a week of hell later
I injection hearsay overruled
um Johnny at one point
um slapped me in the face in our bedroom
in the Chateau that we were staying in
um at another moment he punched me
across the jaw
at one point
um
he kind of either pushed or or through
it's hard to describe to you which of
those two it is because
I I can't tell you I just know I went
flying into this old church furniture
uh I later thought I had a concussion
uh it was the first time I thought I I
had sustained a concussion
um and that's
I wrote about it later
now did did there come a time in this
time frame that you found a folder on Mr
Debb's computer
yes what was it labeled
it was on Johnny's um opening page his
desktop it said no fun for JD in all
caps and what was in that folder
uh it was a it was a collection of
pictures of me from various red carpets
starting on the Press tours that I had
been on
um where I've zoomed in pictures of
what he thought was you know like
inappropriate clothing side boob
cleavage anytime I moved instruction
calls for speculation
all right I'll sustain as to what she
believes it was okay
okay and I saw of the kind of rose gold
dress and the red dress were both in
that file
now what
I want to say to you or ask you
what those cuts on your arms
nothing
what if anything has Mr Depp ever said
to you or asked you about any injuries
that you've sustained over those years
Johnny's obviously never asked me how I
got any of those scars
witness Mr Depp
self-injuring himself
uh often he did that often please tell
the jury about that what did he do I
first started
um
[Music]
I first started
I can't tell you what I told my
therapist but
um
I almost called 9-1-1 in New York in
2014 August of 2014 I believe because I
thought he had done himself an injury he
often in fights would cut his arms or
hold a knife to his chest or draw blood
superficially superficially at first but
later like in 2016 especially as our
relationship was ending
um oh he also put cigarette cigarettes
out on himself
um he'd flicked them at me
um and once or twice tried to put one
out on me but mostly he would do it
while screaming at me he once did it
right in front of me screaming
um
at my face as he as he put the cigarette
out on his cheek
now I'm going to take you to September
15 2015 and Michelle if we can bring up
a Deb exhibit that's plaintiff's exhibit
345 a this is another audio recording
and it's five colon 5'4
to 7 colon 5 5.
I'd like to move the admission any
objection
no objection all right 345 a in evidence
thank you
if you can play Michelle please
um whoever's gonna party one I'm not
home you should
I don't have any controller or how much
you drink
but you don't have any controller or
whether I tell you the truth
have you changed lately yeah you've
changed
your truth is really interesting too
okay yeah well I'm the first person
that's noticed so I can go downstairs
okay
I suppose
of course 15 minutes just like last time
just like last time
we need I had to pull you out of the
bathroom well
when you passed out naked in the
bathroom and
digital me huh he tried to
yeah
it didn't get inside
by pounding on the door waking up every
15 minutes and then falling asleep next
to the door if I could hear you snoring
case that you vomited I could call EMS
if you ever stop snoring
I thought you would choke on your own
vomit which is very likely with you
really yes yes
what yes we do vomit a lot in your sleep
good
oh it's nice here then this is affecting
you a lot more than I thought it was
[Music]
so good
I hope uh
[Music]
all right
[Music]
please explain to the jury what the
issue was in this particular tape
recording
well
Johnny at the time was
um wanting to go and drink uh downstairs
at a bar and we were talking about 15
minutes because the last several times
he had done that it had been days and he
disappear on a bender get really sick
and you know the drill by now having
heard enough from me
um so another issue that we were having
at the time or that he was having at the
time that affected me is that he would
pass out and vomit and vomited very very
regularly at this stage she was
obviously drinking again I'd given up
fighting with him on that at that stage
and what I had a habit of doing is
turning him over onto his side so he
doesn't choke on his own vomit
um it's very common for people who do
that to fixate at least that's what I
understood so
the advice I got was to turn him to his
side put a pillow underneath his back
and turn his his head so that he didn't
asphyxiate
and uh one time I was doing that and he
swung at me and
um I told Medical
and the advice after I got their advice
I realized I can't say what the advice
was but after I got that advice I
stopped doing that I tried to as much as
I could leave him
uh and just be ready ready to call 9-1-1
or help if I heard him choking
and sometimes that happened behind
bathroom doors
well and that's going to take me to
September 27 2015 again depth that's
plaintiff's exhibit
356 A and the recording is 3107 to 32
30.
I'm going to move the admission in your
honor
any objection to that
no objection all right 36 356 A in
evidence thank you thank you
why and that you punched me in the
[ __ ] thing and you speak in the face
and you said no [ __ ] I didn't what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
and I watched you lie and then by the
way you I'm sorry that I didn't uh
across the face in a proper prophet's
life but I was kidding you it was not
punching you but you're not punched
don't tell me what it feels like to be
punched you know even a lot of thoughts
no no when you [ __ ] have a closed
fist
I don't know what the promotion of my
actual hand was but you're you're fine
and not hurt you and not punch you I was
hitting you how are your toes what am I
supposed to do
how are you doing you're bitching about
it am I you are that's the difference
between you you're a [ __ ] baby
because you start physical fights baby
because you start physical fights
yeah you did so I had to get the [ __ ]
out of there yes
every single time
there's not a physical fight but one
thing she said
you're still being abnormal right you
just like
running away
Amber please explain to the jury what's
transpiring in that audio recording what
that's about well there's
there's two different there's two
different situations that we're
referencing in this fight two different
altercations between Johnny and I
involving the door
the first of which which we first start
talking about where I'm talking about
hitting him I am talking about the what
that conversation is about is about the
disparity
uh the disparity between Johnny and I in
our physical fights the disparity of how
he would proactively punch me
and I would have to resort to reactively
hitting him I am talking about the
difference between a punch
Johnny did often and me having to hit
him in my defense
I know the difference between those two
and I'm highlighting the difference
between those two even if he wasn't
twice my size they're very different and
that's what I'm pointing out to him
the situation that that involved the
context of that is it happened in our
bedroom up in in Penthouse three you've
heard us talk about that place and I was
trying to shut a door our bedroom door
actually I was trying to barricade
myself behind the store and Johnny was
trying to get through the door he was
using his body and his limbs to try to
bust through the door as I was trying to
keep it closed because I knew what he
would do to me when he got to me on the
other side
and I was hitting his arms uh his his
arms his body as he was trying to
to prevent me from closing the door
and that is a separate incident that we
later talk about in the second half of
that recording where we're talking about
my toes that involved a different
incident
which was a bathroom door and it was one
of those ones that he was passing out in
and I could hear him passing out or what
it sounded like to me behind a closed
doors passing out I heard a thud I heard
a lot of commotion I heard a glass break
and I hear what sounds like his body uh
falling against the bathroom door I open
it to check on him as I was accustomed
to doing at that time
Johnny violently reacted to me opening
the door pushed it against me it ran up
over my toes and he angrily came around
the side of the door swinging at me I
naturally pushed the door off of my feet
responding to the pain and also to the
awareness the knowledge that he was
coming for me
Johnny later
um denied well later he blamed me in his
inability to understand what happened in
that he was not in his right mind and he
misunderstood that interaction and tried
to blame me for starting a a physical
fight between us
and he even later went so far to say I
wasn't even going to hit you
and
um
that was the that was the second door
I only can I only could respond by
trying to take accountability for my
actions in it what he understood my
actions were and my interpretation and
what I'm trying to say to him is look
I can only do my best to respond I was
in pain I was scared and I can't promise
you that when I'm scared and in pain
and I won't react thinking I know very
well what our situation is and what's
gonna happen to me should I not react
thank you
so let's I'm going to play another clip
from that same discussion and you're
under the plaintiff's exhibit that's 5
356 B we will call that and it would be
from one colon 29 colon 27 to 1 colon 30
colon 07 and I'd like to move the
admission
all right any objection no objection
your honor all right 356 be in evidence
thank you
I'm wrong with you I won't get physical
again God I [ __ ] sometimes get so mad
I lose it
I can [ __ ] promise you I'm you know
everything to change
I promise you I'm not gonna go around
divorce I will not feel divorce enough
unless it's it and then I hope you leave
me
not going to need to I will leave you
it's fair I can't do it you know and I
think honestly if we hold each other
accountable to that
it's fair
please explain to the jury what was
going on in that part of the discussion
that's the same conversation
um where I am as I was accustomed to
doing I'm taking as much responsibility
as I had to in those interactions I have
to
you know in my relationship with Johnny
and as you have to and somebody will not
and cannot take any accountability for
anything they do in a fight as Johnny
couldn't and wouldn't
um I took on as much as I could for
myself
um you know I had the whole relationship
been
blamed for everything for his drinking
for him hitting me for everything in
between
blame for walking away blame for staying
and I blame myself as well
um blame myself for my part in it wait
blame myself for staying blame myself
for putting up with it and frankly at a
certain point it's easier to take the
blame feels easier
it almost feels better to take the blame
for something than to accept the
senseless nature of the violence you
can't change
you know there's all it's almost more
reassuring to take accountability for it
than to accept
the senseless nature of the violence
that you can't change no matter what you
do no matter what I did
no matter what I did still hit me
[Music]
October 5
2015 and you're under plaintiff's
exhibit Deb's exhibit 393 a it's another
recording two colon 40 to 3 colon 43.
move the admission
no objection all right 393 a plaintiffs
in evidence
Johnny they don't know none of your
friends whether they saw a tiny fraction
that was the tip of an iceberg
tip of an iceberg that was my reaction
to yet again this happening
that is the tip of the ice cream
is like mental if it's a validation of
of whatever of telling your friends or
whatever they think or whatever they
think about me or whatever
fine but they only saw a tip of an
iceberg none of your friends let me ask
you questions have actually been there
for one of our fights they've never
actually seen
have they been in the hallway yeah
is absolutely not true they have not
heard everything because you quoted us
great he can quote a part of it but he
has not been there no one has actually
been there for a a fight in its entirety
no how could they no exactly so stop
using that it's some sort of excuse like
they see it they know they work for you
or they're your friends
please explain to the jury what you were
discussing in that conversation
Johnny would often use the fact that his
you know paid employees his loyal staff
would back him up in fights
and that they would he would constantly
threaten to call them in to validate him
they threatened to call them to come
into the room to have them back up him
and say that it was you know that my
yelling or that I'm at fault that I'm in
the wrong that it's all me and he would
do that and and that almost all of our
fights especially at 2000 by 2015 that
he would call his friends and he'd call
his staff into to back him up so that I
knew and would accept that I'm at fault
and that I met I'm wrong and that was
you know what I had to agree to over and
over again just even hope that we could
have a conversation at some point in a
more therapeutic sense so we could move
the conversation along
um that that was his Mo if you will you
call people that work for him to back
him up
I'm going to take you to Thanksgiving 20
20 tell the jury and and go through this
one relatively briefly but tell the jury
about Thanksgiving and and any
altercations you had with Mr Depp on
that occasion
uh Thanksgiving 2015 we had friends uh
over uh Johnny had Marilyn Manson over
and I had a few of my friends over
we had a son over and um maybe
um maybe my father I'm not entirely sure
how long he was there
we had dinner together
um Johnny uh was disappearing with
Manson
um doing coke the objection calls her
speculation all right just seeing that
objection how do you know he was
disappearing with Mr Manson with Coke
um
that's what I knew of their relationship
at the time objection calls for
speculation not sustained objection AI
so please continue he got up for a
longer period of time
um not the normal every five minutes to
go to the bathroom kind but like he
disappeared for a long period longer
period of time and at this stage I was
really
um dependent on recognizing the patterns
of what he was I was reliant on trying
to figure out what he was on what
combination he was on so I knew how to
deal with him
it was incumbent you know on me because
it affected my safety dealing with
somebody who was really high
do you know Johnny high on coke and and
speed meaning Adderall or some version
of that is different from the opiate
Johnny which is different from the booze
Johnny or a different combination and
there was talk of Quaaludes at the time
and Johnny was trying to get it from
objection your honor non-responsive
sustained objection if anyone else so I
was discontinued so I I wanted to know
what I was dealing with it was important
to my safety to know which objection
non-responsive I think that's why I
followed him
so what did you expect I'll sustain the
objection next question what did you do
next I went upstairs to the apartment
the main apartment not the apartment
that we were celebrating Thanksgiving in
uh to try to figure out what was going
on
and we had an argument it took place
downstairs
and I said something to provoke Johnny I
went up the stairs ahead of him
um to get back to the party uh he
grabbed me at the top of the stairs kind
of through the stairs actually by my
shirt
um kind of
flung me a little bit but I I just
remember I went into the bedroom kind of
retreated into the bedroom
uh I had a glass of wine in my hand at
the time which spilled everywhere and
shattered and I kind of retreated into
the bedroom
um Johnny came in after me and there was
this um heavy like vintage style glass
skin decanter
he picked up the decanter and hurled it
at my head my face it missed uh
thankfully but smashed into a piece of
art behind me in the bedroom wall above
the bed
I
[Music]
I got uh passed him I think there might
have been a bit of shoving I can't
really recall and the sequence of when
that happened but I went I wanted to go
back downstairs
and uh I passed my closet I had to
change my shirt
and um
I went back downstairs to the party to
finish the evening out and I put on a
you know a face and we finished the
evening with the guests and then more
fighting uh happened after afterwards
so we talked about December 15 2015 last
Thursday and also the Bahamas over the
holidays
um but I did miss one picture and
Michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 5 18.
Amber does that accurately depict the
scene portrayed
yes it does your honor I'd like to move
the admission of defendants exhibit 518.
no objection all right 518 defendants
and evidence you can publish and this is
from December 15. I believe could you
just please tell the jury what this
depicts
yes so it's um
a picture of my Bruce Temple
um and Johnny had his
hand on my uh on part of my face with my
face down
um
and
um I was punching my head
you know I'm repeatedly punching my head
that's what caused that bruise in my
temple thank you
now we went through the Bahamas before
and you returned from the Bahamas
sometime late December early January
correct
yes okay I'm going to take you to
January February of 2016. can you please
describe to the jury what was going on
with you and Johnny in this January time
frame after this December 15 and the
Bahamas incidents
after the Bahamas
um
Johnny sobriety fell apart there was
just none of it it was
um
uh so he stopped communicating with the
medical team that he had hired objection
culture speculation
um how do you know that
um I was there
um they fired him objection calls for
hearsay I'll sustain objection okay
um without telling what the medical
people did go ahead and tell what was
going on with you and Johnny
um yeah his
uh his mental health for lack of what it
looked like his mental health was just
falling apart it's what it looked like
objection calls for speculation
what did You observe that led you to
believe that his mental health was
falling apart he was objection your
honors culture speculation
I'll sustain objection as to Leading
next question what if anything did You
observe about Mr Depp's uh state
he was hallucinating auditory objection
calls for speculation I
he
stay in the objection please tell the
jury exactly what he was doing that led
you to believe he was hallucinating
objection leading sustained what if
anything was Mr Depp doing that would
have led you to believe he was
hallucinating
sustained what please describe what Mr
Depp was saying in January of 2016. uh
he was talking to people who weren't
there
meaning people who were not in the room
he was communicating with people and
sounds and voices that weren't there I
know because I was sometimes in the room
and sometimes on the phone with him
and he would tell me I had a
conversation with him that I did not
have he would say I said something that
I didn't have he would comment on
somebody being in the room behind me
that wasn't there
it was terrifying
it was terrifying because you know once
he smashed a board right next to my face
and it was unclear to me whether he was
even mad at me or he was convinced that
the guy he said he saw me with was in
the room I didn't know if he was in if
Johnny felt the man was in the room with
us or not at that point but I remember
he put his fist through a white a white
board in the kitchen
he hallucinated right in front of me
instruction calls for speculation don't
use the word hallucinate just describe
what led you to believe your honor
objection of sustain the objection she
can testify to what she observed please
thank you your honor please tell the
jury what you want or maybe we approach
okay
but I tell the jury what you observed
um
I observe behavior from him that was
erratic irrational and didn't seem
connected to the reality that we were in
now I'm going to take you up to the
beginning of February of 2016 February 8
February 9. please tell the jury what
transpired then with respect to Mr Depp
around this time uh Johnny was
again behaving in a way it was very
scary it was terrifying
um and sometimes he didn't know
objection calls for speculation
I think she can describe what she's what
are you are you describing what you're
observing yes please then please
continue
um in these kind of discussions I would
have around this time early February of
2016 uh sometimes in the argument he
would accuse me of something some person
in the room with me that had just walked
out or I was hiding for instance
and sometimes he would hold on to that
even when he seemed to have calmed down
or come off of whatever Bender he was on
and it was almost as if I had to
confront what he what delusion he had or
what belief he had or what accusation he
made of me
um in a new fight altogether you know
sometimes he didn't make it clear to me
whether he was mad at me or he knew he
was mad at me it was terrifying
because I wore the brunt of it and at
around the eighth or ninth I got
we were in his sweet sir compound the
West Hollywood collection of homes that
he has
and I got some cryptic texts from him in
the early morning hours that scared me I
won't say
what I said but I I came over to his
main house
I believe I'd been across the street and
I slept on the couch
we had some interaction in the morning
which made me fearful he didn't know
whether or not I was fearful he was
going to believe that he was angry at me
even though we weren't fighting I wasn't
fighting with him I I had done nothing
wrong but I was really worried that the
momentum he was on was going to click
into a direction of
deciding that he was mad at me and I
deserved it and I was terrified that
that was going to happen so I was
I had an interaction with him and got
really worried about that on the morning
of the 10th all right Michelle I'm going
to ask you to bring up defendants
exhibits 6 38 it's already admitted in
evidence your honor
and this is from February 10 2016.
and I'm going to ask you to play it
Michelle
[Music]
ah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] what happened
what happened
[Music]
foreign
happened this morning you know that
you're here
no so then nothing happened to you this
morning yeah you're right I just woke up
and you were so sweet and nice
[Music]
we're not even fighting this morning all
I did was say sorry did something happen
to you this morning I don't think so
um no that's the thing you want to see
crazy
oh you're crazy are you crazy have you
drunk this whole thing this morning
you got this going oh really
[Music]
you were smashing [ __ ]
laughs
why did you videotape this Amber
because I knew he
wouldn't remember the objection I
answered speculation sustain
is that what you thought just tell us
why you I was afraid
it's scary scary
scared scared they wouldn't remember her
objection calls her speculation
all right
so I'm going to now take you out to
April 21
2016 your 30th birthday party
um will you please tell the jury what
happened that night with respect to in
particular Mr Depp
um
he
uh
at that time we had a like a fitting
that day or the day before and he missed
it and he was kind of Disappearing at
that time
um like at night
um vaguely saying like meetings he had
meetings but then he'd be gone for
sometimes like two days
I'm just not coming home and that sort
of thing coming home after a bender
calls for speculation as to Bender
I I don't think that calls for
speculation a sustain the objection he's
gone for two days good and
I had my my birthday was coming up and
or on my birthday I said well you know
you know are you gonna make it to my my
birthday party we had a dinner planned
at our penthouse
I said it would be important for me if
you if you made an objection hearsay
not offered to prove the truth thank you
and uh
he told me at some point that day that
he had scheduled a business meeting or a
money meeting I think he said maybe
uh seven
uh which is around the time my birthday
was
planned for I might have been planned
for 8 pm
um
he
of course once my party was starting it
wasn't there
um text me at some point to let me know
that he was going to make it but that he
was running late and that continued
throughout my party we finished dinner
and
um we were cleaning up and kind of
everyone was delaying leaving because we
were waiting for
to give him an opportunity to show up
before it was before everyone left
um and he
um he let me he let me know he was there
um
you know I I tried to
without saying what I said I tried to
give him the impression that I wasn't
going to get on him about drinking or
anything I just wanted him to be there
and we had a toast we did a celebratory
toast
um and the guests left
and uh later that
evening we were in bed and
I was I had a book and Johnny
um
effectively said which which was your
[ __ ] problem now
and uh at the time we were getting
advice
from therapists without saying what they
said
um
it was important for me not to make him
feel attacked
uh so I chose my words carefully I won't
say what I said but I remember I
remember being very careful about how I
worded what I was feeling
um about
my birthday and him having missed it
uh
an argument
um followed that
I got up out of bed
um Johnny side of the bag was closer to
the door than mine
I I remember blocking the door blocking
me to get out and kind of shoving me
down and we had a you know a verbal
argument and then that became a shoving
match I tried to shove him back
um I kind of felt myself Retreat into
the into the bedroom at some point he
um picked up a like a large I guess it's
a magnum size not a normal size a large
size bottle of champagne and hurled it
at me
um this time it went through a painting
and I loved this painting I remember I
just went right through the canvas left
a giant hole in it
and
um
after thinking we shouldn't have art in
our bedroom anymore
um and
the the fight the argument the fight
continued into the salon area which was
outside of our bedroom at the top of the
stairs
Johnny picked up my phone I don't know
why uh I don't remember what he was
saying when he did it but he picked up
my phone and threw it out of the open
window of the salon area
out onto the street out onto the
downtown street that
um this window overlooked
uh in that moment I
I went oh no you don't I saw his on the
countertop and picked it up and threw
his immediately like two seconds later
um I didn't want to be stranded uh this
time alone meaning I didn't want to be
the only one stranded without a phone
which had happened to me already several
times before this
um from Johnny so I picked up his phone
through it as well
um and I said that I wanted to go stay
somewhere else for the evening I left
that room went into the office
um
we were still screaming names at each
other and screaming at each other
and I walk around the side of his desk
and the next thing I know he has me by
the Herring pulls me down kind of I hit
the side of the desk I remember things
flying off of the side of the desk that
that I hit with with my body
um I remember trying to
fight him off of me
um
at some point uh
we're back in my my main bedroom
and uh it's my I believe I was getting
my toothbrush out of that bathroom and
uh when I came out we had another
shoving match but this one he kind of
like I remember he chest bumped me
in this like broey way chess bumped me I
fell to the floor and when I got back up
he kind of held me down by the shoulders
down on the side of the bed kind of
held me
um wrestled me down on the bed I
remember I got up once or twice before I
ended up on the bed and he grabbed me
did this thing that he did sometimes
when he taught me grabbed me by the
the pubic
bone pubic
area just as best I can describe it is
you kind of just
pushed me down held me down by it and
kind of pulled me into it and
um was asked he was asking me kind of
taunting me asking me if I if I thought
I was so [ __ ] tough I think you're
such a [ __ ] tough guy huh are you so
tough now look who's so tough you want
to be a man
tough like a man now
that
have happened for about
a bit of time I I not quite
sure
um I think at some point he left I
remember at some point shortly
after that I remember he was still in
the apartment when this happened but I
remember
kind of
collapsing on the floor and
being exhausted
it's just I remember feeling exhausted
and crying and kind of throwing in the
towel if you if you will I remember
saying to him just can we not fight like
this they're like can we start over is
there anything that we can do
like this is
really messed up but can we just not do
this please
can we stop doing this just don't leave
it's my birthday let's just let's let's
just call it couch let's call it truce
and not have it end like this I don't
want to have it in like this
I was just so tired
hurt and I remember crying and feeling
ridiculous
that after this I would be crying and
saying these things
I'm embarrassed saying it now
um
he responded uh
cruelly he told me it's what I [ __ ]
deserve and that I'd wake up every I'd
wake up alone
um and that no one would ever love me
because all of this pointing to my face
or body all of this was gonna go away no
one would ever loved me it might sound
no one ever loved me and I better get
used to waking up alone
um and he
said this is all my fault and what I do
what I asked for and he left I heard him
come back in
uh the downstairs you know you can hear
the door slam I remember hearing it open
and thinking oh God is this gonna happen
again what's going on now
um and and then shortly after I kind of
peeked around to the top of the stairs
where you can kind of peer into the
lower level
and I uh I just see him briefly
momentarily and he just screams at me
happy [ __ ] birthday
and stormed out
at some point I walked downstairs and
saw that he had also left me a note to
that effect
how did he leave a note for you
I was written on a piece of paper as the
best I can recall but I'm not sure
and so then
the next day what did you do
um
I texted actually I took well I can't
say what I texted I Woke Up This that
morning the morning of my 30th birthday
and
um I woke up to my best friend crawling
in bed with me
um and putting her arms around me
and uh
I remember wondering how she got
how she walked in
because there's like glass on the floor
there's lots of glass
and
um she put her arms around me and showed
me a birthday video that all of my
friends my childhood friends all of my
loved ones made of course stupidly the
first thing I asked her is why Johnny
wasn't in the video because it had been
recorded before it had been recorded
sometime before it was clear
uh and she said um
that she'd been asking for a few months
and Johnny objection your honor here say
um
and so I um
i i i i i Pat we eventually we got out
of my bed and
um grabbed a few things and uh got the
bat got the dogs
um left for for
um our plans which our plans had been to
go to Coachella which is a music
festival that happens in California
um and that had been the plan for a
while that that's how we would go and
celebrate my birthday and I remember you
know um as I am accustomed to doing just
trying to move through move on and
remember in vain trying to
put on a brave face and have a good time
even though it was impossible
let me stop you for a few things what if
any plans were there for Mr Depp to join
you at Coachella
he was
supposed to drive down have dinner stay
in if in the room maybe do some writing
or something like that in the room
Coachella at Coachella where we were
Coachella happens in a different part of
California than we lived in we lived in
Los Angeles and this happens about two
hours two to three hours away
um so I finally gotten my car back and
um and I drove with my best friends in
in the car and I'm gonna stab you again
because I just have a couple more
questions before we go into that part uh
you said you brought the dogs who were
the dogs you brought
uh Johnny's dog at the time boo my dog
pistol we shared them their teacup
Yorkies and I believe Raquel my best
friend's dog which is a mutt okay what
if any issues did Boo have with uh
bathroom problems if you will objection
leading and relevance overruled I love
it
um
she had eaten uh Johnny's weed when she
was a puppy and had a bowel control
issues for her entire life among some
other issues who's you know we regularly
had to take her to the vet to try to
figure out
well what was wrong with this dog never
met a dog that was quite like this so
she had some control issues
hence why we would she like to burrow in
the bed and she liked to be in the you
know by the foot of the bed underneath
the covers and it was um customary that
they slept in bed with us but boo
having the issues she had we have to
leave her in bed so that she wouldn't be
encouraged to to go to the bathroom
which would happen almost immediately
once you put her down on the floor and
sometimes it happened in bed too but
um
but yeah so what if anything did you
notice about any bathroom issues in your
bed before you left for Coachella
well Raquel and I were both in in that
bed
um with the dogs and I didn't notice
anything but we left them in the bed
while we packed a bag
to go to Coachella you know so that
they didn't so that boo particularly
didn't lose control of her about or you
know didn't go to the bathroom on the
floor so we leave him in bed until
you're ready to take him outside to the
patio which is their designated bathroom
break area
and what if any plans were there how
often did you have housekeeping at that
time at your house
um the housekeepers were there every
morning
or they came every day as far as I know
now we'll get you to Coachella but why
did you tell Starling Jenkins that you
had been involved in a prank gone wrong
objection hearsay leading I said why
your honor I didn't say what she said
I'll sustain the objection next question
okay
um
did you commit any kind of prank
absolutely not
absolutely not and and why
would that not be something you would do
first of all I don't think that's funny
I don't know what
a grown woman does I I was not also in a
pranking mood I had my life was
falling apart I was um
at a Crossroads in my life I was really
serious and I had just been attacked on
my 30th birthday
by my violent husband with whom I was
desperately in love
and knew I needed to leave
it was uh not really a jovial time
and I don't think that's funny period
that's disgusting
what Finney
understanding did you have of Mr Depp
coming back to your bedroom that night
or the next morning
objection culture speculation I'm asking
what are understanding what I'll sustain
the objection okay did you had you had
any conversations with Mr Depp about him
coming back to the house the next day no
Johnny didn't come back to that house
that was my that was my you know he
owned it but that was my house when when
we were having any sort of problem in
fact that was my house just 90 percent
of the time because he just didn't come
back
that was not a place that Johnny was
going to be in that Johnny was in and he
had stormed out on my birthday and as
per what we did it was he would go and
stay at his West Hollywood home and I
would stay at the downtown places
he wasn't going to come back to the
instruction culture speculation
explained her answer
which is the same just the last part
okay next question thank you all right
so let's take you to Coachella
um who drove
I drove
and who was in your vehicle
my sister my friend Savannah I believe
my best friend Raquel
just my my girlfriends I I typically
surround myself with my girlfriends it's
my sport
was there any
were riding in the vehicle that Starling
Jenkins was driving
he picked us up from Coachella in the
evening when we as a group all were
ready to leave that was the
um the day that we went which was a um
which was a day that I took in BMA and
mushrooms at the same time realized very
shortly after what a horrible idea that
was considering the state that my life
was in I highly don't recommend that
combination at the time so I didn't feel
like being in a crowd I didn't feel like
being at Coachella I had intended to try
to have a good time despite what was
going on in my personal life and I
realized that
that was just not gonna happen and so I
wanted to go home I wanted meaning to be
in a bed I wanted to be
you know I just wanted to be held by my
best friend and watch a movie and that's
what we did I didn't feel well and
wanted to leave
when you said you rode back with
Starling Jenkins was it just you or did
you have other people in the vehicle
with you
um when we left Coachella it was my
entire group I wasn't ever alone with
Starling I certainly wasn't anywhere
near him I didn't have a conversation
with him I sat in the very back seat
with my best friend next to me and it
was a whole group of us thank you
um you're under this this might be a
good breaking all right that's fine okay
let's go ahead and take our morning uh
recess to not discuss the cases with
anybody and don't do the outside
research we'll take 15 minutes okay
thank you
foreign
all right we ready for the jury yes sir
okay sure sure
foreign
okay
foreign
thank you
does that make sense okay
all right ready for the jury again
all right
what if any contact that you have with
Mr Depp During the period from April 21
to May 21 2016.
I had no physical contact with him okay
take you to
second 2016 the Met Gala
can you please just briefly describe to
the jury what a Met Gala is where it is
and what's involved
uh it's arguably the biggest
um
fashion
kind of celebrity event red carpet event
of the year it happens every year in New
York City
and Were you invited I was invited um
typically designers will invite
people in the public eye to be there
um you know guest and they will
typically dress them and it's a way for
designers or fashion to kind of
intersect with the a celebrity world and
and it's a big event held at the Museum
every year
and what if anything did you and Mr Depp
do to prepare for that Met Gala
well Johnny and I were
we were
dressed by Ralph Lauren guests of Ralph
Lauren uh and Johnny missed the fitting
uh in because it was happening around
the date of my birthday party in Los
Angeles but we were planning on going
um together as Ralph Lauren's guests
and did you show up
I did um I didn't have a phone at the
time because uh I couldn't get it
reinstated after Johnny threw it out of
the window because no one on his team
would would respond to me um so I had no
way to kind of reinstall it I had
um it's no point in getting a burner
phone if you don't know anyone's phone
number so I um
uh I I wasn't sure really what was going
on or when he would show up or if he
would show up no one would talk to me on
his team no one would tell me I didn't
know
so I ended up going by myself
um frankly I wasn't sure if he'd show up
and you know on the carpet or if you'd
show up at the hotel shortly before
um I I had no way of knowing
and then did you attend the Met gal
a I did I
I got out of the car and walked the red
carpet by myself escorted by somebody
from
Ralph Lauren's team
um
and I sat next to an empty place setting
for Johnny that they they cleared as
soon as we realized that he wasn't
that he effectively stood me up on the
carpet
I was standing in line
um right in front of a gentleman it was
Elon uh I didn't recognize him
um until we we started talking
and he had reminded me that we had met
once before he was with his mother
and did you strike up a friendship with
Mr musk after that
we did we as I mentioned we spoke on the
on the red carpet kind of on the waiting
in the waiting line of the carpet
um he seemed like a real gentleman he
was really nice and he's not next to me
well not next to me he saw it kind of in
a nearby table and we got to speaking
that night and then eventually became
friends
okay
I'm going to Michelle can you pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 46. it's already in
evidence it's Aaron filotti's notes and
I'm going to ask you to go to page 30.
and I'm going to direct your attention
to the entry for 5 11 2016.
where it says uh
if I can see
here we go let me let me see if I can do
some reasonable
highlighting here
okay it says client laughed and also
reported using illicit drugs mushrooms
and MDMA on 5 9 2016 at home with a high
profile male acquaintance Court client
reported that her husband was not aware
of the male visitor nor her illicit drug
use do you see that
yes I do who who was the high-profile
male acquaintance that would visited
your home on 5-9 2016.
I don't recall even being in La at that
time where were you I don't recall uh I
believe I was in London at the time okay
um did you have a male high-profile
client at your home in or around five
nine two thousand sixteen uh not around
that date it seems like it's a wrong
date okay and did you use illicit drugs
mushrooms and MDMA with any high profile
client uh no I did that at the Coachella
Music Festival and that was the end of
that I learned the hard way that that
was a terrible idea all right
all right well while we are on
on these same notes I'm gonna say I'm
going to refer to the Coachella which is
up above and it says it states she
ingested mushrooms and MDMA
simultaneously while also consuming
alcohol in states she vomited and was
high for at least 24 hours straight were
you high for at least 24 hours straight
no I was not I I felt awful
um but I was at home feeling awful at
home meeting at the hotel
with my best friend in bed okay well
while I'm still on these notes let's go
I know
um while Aaron flatty was was testifying
we recall the 521 2016 isn't on here uh
you'd send her pictures correct yes I
did then let's go to 526 2016 and it
says client reports having the hardest
week of my life client states she cannot
deal with the negative media publicity
she has received and then if we can jump
that up Michelle to the next page
surrounding the divorce she requested
from her husband JD do you see that I do
okay when did you go in for the dvtro
May 27th so that was the day after Aaron
fellati's note saying you just had the
toughest week of your life that's
correct okay
we are still on this one let's go up to
the first page
for the client history
when did you provide a client history to
Aaron fellati
okay never
when did you first get assigned Aaron
fellati uh I believe September of
2014. okay now it says here
that client
um
reports a history of substance abuse
including an addiction to cocaine and
liquor
when did you have a substance a history
of substance abuse including addiction
to cocaine and liquor
I did not there's a lot of mistakes in
here okay
okay did you ever use cocaine I have I
used cocaine a few times when I was 18
19 years old
um but stopped using
um any drugs including cocaine when I
got into a relationship with my
ex-partner she was very against that and
I'm glad for it okay
then it also says here that
move up a little here we go client
admits to history of anxiety eating
disorder attention deficit disorder
bipolar disorder codependence issues and
occasional insomnia when have you had an
eating disorder I've never had an eating
disorder
when have you been diagnosed with
bipolar disorder I've never been
diagnosed with bipolar disorder when
have you been diagnosed with
codependence issues I have never been
diagnosed with codependency issues
although arguably at the time from where
I well at from where I stand now I can
see that the relationship I was in with
with Johnny was certainly codependent
but I wouldn't have reported that at the
time I didn't know about that all right
and then can we move up a little bit
more show
thank you it has per report from JD
Debbie RN Dr Kipper
client ah has reportedly been
experiencing increased anxiety and
agitation recently and has had several
outbursts of anger and rage were you
present for this being reported to Ms
fellati no this is the detox
okay this is Johnny's
and it also says your mood has been
labile what if any outbursts of anger
and rage and labile mood did you exhibit
during the detox
none that she would have seen none I I
was there for Johnny's detox this is
what Johnny was going through this is
not me okay and at the time of the detox
was Aaron fellati your nurse yet no I
didn't know her and she wasn't there
okay
it's down Michelle
now I'm going to take you to May 21
2016. and I'd like you to describe for
the jury what took place that evening in
connection with Mr death
Johnny and I had not seen each other for
the better part of a month or about a
month
I was traveling I just shot a campaign
in Italy I spoke to him uh around that
time when I was in Italy uh I had gotten
a phone
my parents got a hold of me
after I spoke to my parents I
communicated with Johnny
he on that phone call you know I didn't
know what was going on with him for
those weeks
with his sobriety I didn't know where
his state was I didn't know what
State he was in and when I spoke to him
he
um was saying what I can only just he
was going on about
um
about scientists and DNA and uh feces
that he had had
um some some
you know scientific
analysis done and DNA analysis done and
that you know as soon as I heard about
this feces he thought that was a prank
and he was going on about all the the
scientists that he had conferred about
the DNA results with I was just thought
he was out of his mind and thought
clearly the drinking and the drugs are
not getting better clearly the delusions
aren't better so speculation
please continue so I um
I hung up from that phone call uh
assuming that and then spoke to him once
once my my parents got a hold of me to
tell me about Betty Sue
we made a plan Johnny and I uh for him
to come over he said he really needed
his wife
um he had lost his mother and he missed
his wife he really needed his wife he
said it over and over again
I felt torn I felt conflicted I didn't
think
obviously the situation hadn't gotten
better with Johnny mentally and I was
afraid that
all the work and progress and distance I
had finally got on it on the
relationship for the first time I had a
month of distance on it you know I
didn't want that to be undone but I also
wanted to be
you know I was affected by the fact that
his mother
had passed so
uh he said he wanted to come over and
talk about that and he said he needed
his wife and
we made a plan I uh we made a plan for
him to come over during the day thinking
that that might mitigate the amount that
he would be drinking night is a little
bit more dangerous
and uh in the early evening hours I get
a text from him that he's almost there
or that he's there I think it was around
7 15 or so
and he came over and we sat on the couch
and at first kind of it was relatively
peaceful I mean I could tell he was
inebriated but makes sense in my head it
made sense
it wasn't he wasn't like incoherent it
was peaceful and then he starts talking
about the feces again and this prank
that he said one of my friends had left
for him in my bed that he wasn't going
to be at
and I tried to point out how that didn't
make any sense I'm not even going to be
there I wasn't there
and my friends wouldn't do that that's
not something a bunch of 30 year old
women think is funny what is he talking
about and he just kept going on and on
about it
so I uh I text my friend that it's
objection hearsay
don't don't tell us don't tell the jury
what you texted your friend but go to
the next thing what did you do next
I uh called my friend thinking that it
would
um quell this what I could only see as a
delusion I thought if it's just a
delusion he was having and I thought oh
I'll I'll
hopefully
you know quell this by calling my friend
to to if he hears my friend say that
didn't happen
it's not out for over the truth please
continue so I thought if I could get my
friend on the phone to to prove that
this didn't happen we could move on and
talk about the issues this that we
should be talking about you know we had
our marriage was over and falling apart
in front of our eyes we hadn't seen each
other for a month and his mom had just
passed I couldn't believe he wanted to
talk about feces
so I call this friend thinking that well
take care of it the friend doesn't
answer I call another friend who is
someone else he claimed I don't know how
both people did this but he was claiming
that this person was responsible so I
called that person
and that person is on speakerphone
and I said who that person is Io Io tell
it right IO tell it right okay and then
you put him on speakerphone with Johnny
right in front of Johnny okay and what
happened next I
I allowed for an opportunity for Io to
say why this is impossible not offered
to prove the truth of the matter is
asserted your honor it's explaining the
context that leads to the next acts your
honor it is being offered to prove
I'll sustain the objection next question
um
all right so IO is talking you can't
tell us what he said okay objection
correct may we approach okay
today
so
I always talking we can't say what he
said what is the next thing that happens
on your end with Mr Depp
um
it just made Johnny matter I even got
more upset grabbed the phone
and started screaming at IO uh
he just started screaming at the top of
his lungs and said you died [ __ ] you
don't know what you're talking you know
just screaming expletives insulting
names
um and
telling IO that he can have me and you
know [ __ ] off and
just screaming at him
um
uh you know as best I can describe it
without getting into the details he
tosses the the phone you know down on
the couch and heads upstairs and I pick
up the phone
and and try to you know apologize
for
the fact that my
husband at the time just screamed at my
friend on a cold call
um I didn't want IO to think that's why
I had called IO you know to just be
screamed at and blamed for something
that sounded crazy for lack of a better
explanation it sounded crazy
i o
um said something to me on speakerphone
um and
um reminded me I wasn't safe
objection honor hearsay here on it's not
offered to prove the truth of the matter
it's to show what caused Mr Depp to be
set off and come back I mean it's not
offered to prove the truth of what he's
saying it's not hearsay and I'll overall
objection thank you please tell us what
IO said and what then happened with Mr
Depp
IO said Amber get out of the house get
out of the house now you're not safe
get out of that house
I had been there after the cleanup or
for the cleanup after December 15 2015
incident and objection responses I think
he should provide that content I'll
sustain the objection next question so
please please continue Johnny here's
this when he's on the stairs he made it
up one flight of stairs
heard this turned around came bolting
down the stairs
grab the phone from my hand
and really really started screaming this
time led into IO uh called IO every
imaginal every imaginable horrible name
that you can say to a LGBT Qi person for
one and and any person any human being
ever I mean just screamed
at IO um
some really nasty stuff and he when he
was done he says you know you want to
you want to have you want to have my
woman now you want to have my [ __ ] you
can have you you take her you can have
her any with that picks up just pulls
his arm back with the phone and throws
it at my face
hit me right in my it felt like my my
eye
I put my head in my hands
and immediately
start crying
I
said you hit me with the phone Johnny
you hit me
and I'm sitting on the couch I didn't
even have time to
react you know I didn't even have time
to put my hands up I was still sitting
cross-legged in my socks
on the couch and I haven't seen him for
a month and last you know several times
now that I've seen him
he's hit me and I didn't even have time
to react to this
he comes over to me
um as I'm crying
and he does that taunting thing to me he
says oh yeah I hit you huh I hit you
yeah
and he just
feels like Wax me on top of my head just
heavy ringed hand landed on top of my
my skull grabs me by the hair Yanks me
up off the couch I'm struggling to stand
up
and I don't know if he was intending to
hit me in the face or if he was just
trying to grab my face but he was making
this gesture around my face to try to
hold to expose my face to him and he was
like yeah let me see how bad I hurt you
let me see it let me see how bad I hurt
you this time what if I pull your hair
back what if I pull your hair back
and he Yanks my hair back I'm trying to
prevent him from Landing the blows to my
face and trying to prevent my face from
being exposed
and I just remember this mocking taunt
he was doing with me as he is yanking me
around the room uh and then I hear my
friend come into the room
um I hear her
Johnny hears her too he lets go of me
and turns and just tell the jury who
your friend is Raquel my
best friend at the time who lived in the
neighboring apartment
she
came in and uh Johnny moved towards
towards her and she ran towards me
Johnny looked at her looked at me I
retreated to the only place I had to go
which is The Corner Room the where the
couch was I retreated kind of to the
couch and Raquel and Johnny both ran up
to me John Raquel got in front of Johnny
she kind of
managed to get right in front of him in
between he and I
and I'll never forget it just very
slowly calm very very in just a very
slow but very concentrated very
controlled slow way just put both of her
arms her hands up like this and like
I've seen people do with horses that's
what it reminded me of she just went
no no Johnny no and she just got in
front of us in between us put her both
of her Palms out Johnny kind of squared
off to her ran into her arms and she
just repeated herself very slowly very
calmly very directly
he hit both of her arms off of his chest
like that
and Barrel towards me I instinctively
curl up on the couch and I just feel her
arms come around me next to me she was
sitting on my left next to me on the
couch and just feel her arms around me
and I'm just looking down at the carpet
feeling her arms and that's when Johnny
who I can see partially and here is
right in front of me and he's screaming
at me to get the [ __ ] up Amber get the
[ __ ] up Amber get the [ __ ] up Amber get
the [ __ ] up and every single time he
said it you screaming it louder and
louder and louder
I think he screamed it probably about 10
times
so loudly
next thing I hear is boss boss and I
realize that his two security guards had
come into the to the apartment after
Raquel
I see them and
or hear them and uh Johnny turns to them
and I I see Jerry say boss boss and I
get up off the couch and I say to Jerry
attraction your honor here say not
offered to prove the truth of the matter
assert it at all sustain the objections
all right next one so don't tell us what
you said to Jerry just what happened
next
uh then they tell him
something
um and uh he uh picks up the the bottle
that I guess he walked in with uh was uh
or Jerry I'm sorry Johnny okay and uh
starts smashing things off the
nightstand the the coffee table starts
screaming
uh and they kind of
I feel them kind of Corral him I'm not
making direct eye contact but I can kind
of just sense and feel and sound and
hear things smashing as he exits the
apartment kind of knocking things off
the countertops and
breaking things on the way I I
um realized he you know he's punching
something I I assume it was the picture
because it it broke right after he
walked past it and he leaves that
apartment I hear him in the hallway
still screaming I hear more doors
opening more racket
eventually Josh Raquel's
husband comes into the room and uh
uh brings me to safety brings for Kel
and I to Safety in
um in their apartment
and that's where I stayed for the next
few hours
so who called the police
I believe it was awesome speculation
you're honor this is that we have to
have the context here of somebody called
the police because then the police come
so I think we have to but I mean it's
not offered again to prove the truth of
the matter asserted it's just who called
the police who honor the objection is
not hearsay it's speculation do you know
who called the police yes I do now
did you have a conver did you were you
present when there was a discussion
about calling 9-1-1 objection calls for
hearsay I'm asking if she was pregnant
sustained an objection next question
did you call 9-1-1 no
did Rocky call 9-1-1 projection culture
speculation do you know whether Rocky
called 9
I do know whether she did and did she
did not okay
um all right so what happens when did
you learn
that the police had been called
roughly an hour I don't
at some point shortly after uh Johnny
and his security guards left
okay what did you do as a result of
knowing that the police were coming
I I felt panicked I'm I I didn't know
what to do because
I didn't know what they were going to do
when they saw
the state of the place he'd also smash
up the other apartment where I kept all
my things so I didn't know what they
were going to do and I panicked I called
um I called the only lawyer I have which
is my entertainment lawyer he does like
my movie contracts and stuff
and I asked him for advice
and then what without telling what he
said what happened next I called a
domestic relations attorney
after that conversation and had you
known this Domestic Relations attorney
before that no I did not did you get
that name from your entertainment
attorney yes I did okay and when you
called The Domestic Relations attorney
without saying what she said what did
you do as a result
I
told the police officers who arrived
that I would not objection your honor
hearsay I cannot offered to prove the
truth of the matter asserted all right
I'll overly objection go ahead thank you
I'm sorry could you repeat that
I repeated to the officers I refused to
cooperate at this time at the advice of
my attorney
um
now I'm going to ask you to take a look
at
some pictures
but before I get there I want to just
ask you a couple of questions leading up
what were you doing when the police
officers arrived
when
at that time when I
after I learned that they were coming
uh
my best friend took pictures of me
we took pictures of the house and my
face
I'm going to and
did your best friend take any pictures
while the officers were there we took
pictures before and while they were
there and after okay we took pictures
throughout
so I'm going to take you now Michelle
can you bring up defendants exhibit 706
I think we can do the native on this one
yes thank you
uh does this accurately depict the scene
portrayed
yes it does your honor I'd like to move
the admission of defendant 706
no objection 706 in evidence
and would you please describe to the
jury what this is a picture of
um this is my face after Johnny threw a
phone at it
I'm going to now Michelle ask you to
pull up defendants 708
and does this accurately depict the
scene portrayed in this picture
yes it does all right and I also see
that there is a a little what we call
metadata item on there how how do you
get that on a picture how does that
happen can you just describe briefly
objection your honor that's speculation
like a foundation
foreign
can you please explain how this
particular item on here got onto the
pictures
it's a it's a feature that was on
um iPhotos you know where the where your
pictures are stored on your phone
typically you just push info
and and was that pushed in this these
instances and that's what came up okay
okay you're right I'm going to move the
admission of defendants 708 we have
objection your honor I would just ask
the picture be redacted um on hearsay
grounds
um
your honor for the metadata okay okay
okay that's fine
okay all right I'm gonna move the
admission of 708 with the redaction year
okay and the objection to that um there
still needs to be another reduction at
the top your honor okay
we'll get it
okay thank you
okay 708 with the redactions okay thank
you your honor and I would also like the
record to reflect that we um we're
publishing this to the jury yes no
objection correct okay
yeah there you go okay I would like the
record to reflect that this was the
photo that was shown to officer signs an
officer had objection
that is inappropriate because we hadn't
identified them now the jury should be
entitled to know which photos that we
approached okay
so for the record this particular photo
was shown to officers signs and officer
Hadden as exhibit 24 in both of the
depositions that were shown earlier
where the pictures were not uh allowed
to be shown yet because they hadn't been
admitted Amber will you please describe
for the jury what what is depicted in
this photo
yes that's a picture of my face
um taken
um that evening shortly before 9 30
um after Johnny hit me with the phone
okay
now we can take this one down and let's
go to defendants exhibit 709
and based on the Court's ruling I'm
going to ask if you can redact that
Michelle please
remove the admission of 709
all right any objection not with
rejections thank you 709 with redactions
and evidence you can publish
it could be published to the jury owner
thank you and your honor for the record
this is the photo that was shown to
officer signs and to officer Hadden as
exhibit 25 for both of their depositions
Amber could you please describe for the
jury what's depicted here
that is my face
after
um after the phone incident
it's that night
Let's uh bring defendant 710 please
and your enemy to move the admission of
exhibit 710 the redactions have been
already placed on it any objection
no objection thank you 710 weather
redaction to be published if we could
publish your honor
and for the record this photo was shown
to officer signs and officer hadn't it
was exhibit 26 for both of their
depositions
and please subscribe for the jury what's
depicted here Amber
that is my face and
uh yet A different light
um that same evening
after Johnny hit me with the phone
okay
let's go ahead and go to defendants
exhibit 711.
and I'm going to move the admission of
711 your honor with the redactions right
and the objections no objection or
7-Eleven with objections evidence
publish
and for the record your honor uh for the
jury's purposes this was shown to
officer signs and officer had in his
exhibit 27 to both of their depositions
could you describe what's depicted here
Amber yes that is another angle another
lighting of my face
uh after the phone
and when you say angler lighting what
did Rocky do in in taking these pictures
Junction calls for speculation I said
what you do go over room thank you uh
Raquel
um took pictures of my face in various
places around the penthouse Penthouse
the apartments have really different
lighting you know really dark in some
places
um anyway so we just took pictures in
different lighting so that um we had an
accurate
portrayal and depiction of what had
happened
and why did you take the pictures
uh Raquel did it to protect me because
the cops were coming and um we knew we
or that we knew that the police I think
at this point that we they were already
here they were with us but we weren't
maybe this was right before I'm not
quite sure without seeing the time stamp
but
we weren't sure what was going to happen
what the police were going to say what
they were going to do
we didn't know what Johnny was going to
do what he was going to say so she
wanted to protect me okay so um let's go
ahead and bring up 712
all right now move the admission of 712
your honor all right any objection no
thank you honor 712 redactions you can
publish
thank you Ryan and please describe
what's depicted here
uh
that is a another picture of my face
okay uh taken around the same time
okay and then let's go to 713
move the admission of 713 your honor all
right any objection
no objection all right 713 with
redactions being published
and for the record this one was shown to
officer signs and officer hadn't as well
as exhibit 29 to both of their
depositions and just describe briefly to
the jury what this is this is uh another
picture of my face taken at the exact
same time and in the same location as
the other one just with one of the
lights turned on or an additional light
turned on in the previous one okay let's
go to 7 14.
move the admission of 714 your honor
no objection all right 7 14 with
redactions
and please tell the jury what this
depicts that says um another angle of my
face or another picture of my face taken
at a different time
I don't know if this is um later before
because I can't see the time on it
now let's go to 7 15.
[Music]
I'm going to move the admission of 715
your honor
no objection all right 7 15 with
reductions in evidence thank you and uh
for the record this one was shown to
officer signs and officer Haddon is
exhibit 17 for both
um please describe for the jury what's
this what's depicted here
that is a picture of my face
um some point later on in the night it
looks like that was taken in Rocky's
apartment or in the apartment that she
was staying in
let's go to 7 16.
move the admission of 7 16.
no objection your honor all right
7 16 evidence says redacted
and Amber could you please tell the jury
what this picture depicts
uh yes it's the business card that one
of the police officers left for me uh in
case I changed my mind and wanted to
comment
with the pictures that we have just seen
before this were they taken before the
pictures of the police
card the card that was left after or do
you know protection compound it's not
and calls for speculation
thank you
uh they we took pictures before during
and after
the question I had
[Music]
before this card was presented to you
and you took the picture after or do you
know
some of them were but without seeing all
the time stamps I can't tell exactly
okay that's fair thank you okay and then
I'm gonna ask you to take this one down
and go to 717.
foreign
thank you and please just briefly
describe to the jury what this is
uh the two officers that
um first responded left me that card
this is the front of the business card
they left
um can you tell the jury just explain
what the interaction was that you had
with the police officers
um just describing what you observed as
they came through
uh
I did not want to speak to them I asked
that Raquel's
partner or husband
asked them to go away without speaking
to me and and we just so the jury
understands who was judging who was
Kell's fiance at that time his name is
Josh Drew and he and Raquel lived in the
apartment at Johnny's invitation across
the hall from us
um Raquel had keys we kind of shared
Keys it was
they were our neighbors but
had keys to our house okay
so why didn't you want to cooperate with
the police
because I I
I wanted to protect Johnny I didn't want
him to be arrested
I didn't want him to be in trouble I
didn't want the world to know
I didn't want this to come out
I didn't want him to be in trouble I
didn't want this to be
I wanted to protect Johnny
let's go to a defendants exhibit 1374.
that's 1374.
one moment here all right
thank you
all right move the admission of 1374 a
your honor any objection no objection
1374 evidence 1374 a in evidence I'm
sorry thank you
um and Amber what is this
it's another picture of my face
after Johnny threw the phone at it okay
and then let's go to 1493t
and move the admission of
1493t no objection all right 1493 T in
evidence
and what does this depict
um this is a picture of
um my eye my face
after that incident perhaps by the
lighting it looks like it might have
been taken the next day but I can't be
telling I mean I can't tell for sure
okay and then let's go to 1493 s
and
move the admission of 1493 s
no objection all right 1493 s in
evidence
and what does this depict and this is
another picture of my eye and
side of my face
now
were there also pictures taken of the
property that you described Mr Deb
uh destroying or damaging
yes there were okay Michelle can you
bring up defendants exhibit 700
and
based on your honors rulings we will
take off the metadata
move the admission of defendants exhibit
700.
no objection with reduction 700 with
redactions you can puff
can you please describe to the jury
what's depicted in this photo
yes my friend had Was preparing for a
beach show and had displays to show
these bead necklaces she made and she
needed some counter space in order to
kind of set up the displays that she was
going to use the next day so she asked
me earlier in the day if she could use
the free counter space in that Penthouse
Penthouse five to kind of set up those
those display racks they were set up in
that room
when Johnny went in there to destroy
things as he does
um and this depicts some of that damage
yeah he
security let him in even though I had
access speculation
uh I I don't think that was speculation
unlock a foundation
oh you also say it's a foundation if you
want okay
um
so
what what does what's depicted what's
the damage that was done well because
Johnny would always smash up my things
and destroy my property when he was mad
at me
um I had asked that they not let him in
to so that he could do that I mean the
only purpose to let for him to be led
into Penthouse five in that state he
doesn't have property in there the only
way for the only reason for him to go in
there would be to destroy it and they of
course let him into Penthouse five
objection that he could go lack of
foundation
all right I'll sustain the objection
next question just tell the jury what he
did here that's depicted in this this is
just a
one corner of the room that shows the
destruction he just went in there with
this bottle swinging and Destroy smashed
a bunch of things objection your honor
this is a speculation she hasn't
established that she was there
oh I'll sustained if you want to live
foundation and so okay yeah
yeah did anybody else to your knowledge
go in there and do this objection your
honor
calls for speculation trying to lay the
foundation here sustaining objection
next question let's do this never mind
we'll let somebody else tell who did it
okay
um just all I'm asking here is what what
is the damage what has been done that's
depicted here this is just one of
Raquel's bead racks that he
um
let's go to 701
move the admission of 701.
with reduction no objection all right
701 with redactions and evidence
Amber can you please describe what's
depicted here
um yeah it is our bedroom and penthouse
three the main Penthouse
um looks like he was just
um throwing things objection you're on
our cost of speculation objection so
just describe what you see here as
opposed to what you say he did okay I
see a bunch of art
um
tossed on the bed okay where was that
art before Mr Depp was at your house on
May 21 2016.
um hanging on the wall where it belongs
let's go to Michelle can you bring up
defendant 702 please
oh your honor that I forgot on the last
two for defendants exhibit 700 that was
shown to officer signs and Haddon it was
exhibit 39 to both of theirs and exhibit
701 was shown to Hadden only and that
was exhibit 30 in his deposition I moved
the admission of 702 please all right
any objection
no objection all right 702 with
redactions thank you your honor and let
the record reflect this was also shown
to officer Hadden as deposition exhibit
number 40.
and can you please describe for the jury
what's depicted here
uh yes it as broken glass from one of
the broke broken
um pictures that were hanging on the
wall
and where is this physically this is in
Penthouse five on the stairwell okay
let's Michelle can you bring up
defendant 703 please
foreign
ition of defendant 703
no objection all right 703 with
redactions you can publish thank you
your honor and the record let the record
reflect that this was shown to officer
signs and officer Hadden as exhibit 41
for both of their depositions
and Amber please describe for the jury
what's depicted here
uh it's another photograph of this
stairwell
in the same apartment Penthouse five
which is the apartment where I kept my
things okay
and is that glass on the stairway yes
from one of the broken picture frames on
the wall we hit a lot of picture I had a
lot of picture frames on the on the
walls and
um
uh many if not most of them were smashed
okay
let's take this one down and go to 704
please defendants
thank you
move the admission of defendant 704
no objection all right 7-4 with
redactions publish thank you and let the
record reflect that this was shown to
both officer signs and hadn't as exhibit
34 to both their depositions
and Amber please subscribe for the jury
what what's depicted here uh just
another
piece of glass that looks like the base
of a wine glass that is in Penthouse 3
the main apartment
and when you say wine glass did you see
this particular
glass there were glasses in the kitchen
and always and when Johnny was walking
out I saw him myself
swinging the Magnum size bottle and I
could hear glass breaking and things
falling okay
thank you Michelle can you bring up 705
please
thank you
move the admission of 705
no reduction no excuse me no objection
all right
705 in evidence thank you thank you go
ahead and let the record reflect this
was shown to officer Hadden and exhibit
36 of his deposition Amber can you
please describe to the jury what's
portrayed here
things knocked over on the kitchen
countertop and I see pieces of broken
glass on the countertop as well
go to 707
move the admission of 707.
any objection
no objection you are all right 707 with
redactions and evidence thank you and
let the record show show that uh both
officer signs and officer hadn't were
shown this picture it was exhibit 18 in
both their depositions Amber could you
please describe to the jury what's
depicted here
this is the hallway leading
um out leading up to the apartments
uh so this is the hallway that connects
all of the apartments it's kind of an
indoor outdoor
um sort of hallway meaning it's covered
but it's
it's exposed on the far ends of both
um to the elements so this is not carpet
it's like a
it's like a plasticky uh I don't know
how to describe the material as like a
plasticky kind of um
um netting not netting it's difficult to
describe but it's a kind of an outdoor
sort of carpet
all right and what's depicted there uh
wine on the floor and a little on the
wall it seems
okay
let's go to 7 18 please
of the admission of 718. no objection
all right 718 with redactions and
evidence and let the record reflect this
was shown to officer signs and officer
Hadden in deposition exhibit 31 for both
of them
ever please describe for the jury what's
depicted here it's um another
another photograph on the floor not the
wall uh this one appears to be
remarkably Unbroken
okay
let's go to 7 19 please
with the admission of defendant 719
uh no objection all right 719 with
redactions thank you thank you your
honor and they let the record reflect
that this was shown to officer signs and
Haddon in their depositions exhibit 35
to both
and Amber please just describe for the
jury what's depicted here
I
at the one corner of the kitchen in
Penthouse three looks like um one of the
one of the things that was knocked off
of the kitchen island when Johnny left
okay
let's go to defendant 720 please
thank you Michelle
move the admission of defendant 720.
no objection all right 720 with
reductions and let the record reflect
you're under this was shown to officer
signs and Haddon deposition exhibit 43
to both
Amber could you please describe to the
jury what's depicted here
that's
um my
office it's a corner of my office
uh and that is
um a box of like
sentimental things things from my
childhood or things that are important
to me keepsake box it
um has been dumped
um out it looks like
it's good
defendant 721
of the admission to defendant 721
no objection your honor 721 with
redactions can be published thank you
your honor and let the record reflect
this was shown to officer signs and
hadn't in deposition exhibit 44 for both
Amber please describe for the jury what
this depicts um it's again my office
different same thing different angle
let's go to 7 22.
move the admission of defendants exhibit
722 no objection your honor 722 with
redactions and evidence thank you and
let the record reflect this was shown to
officer signs and officer Hadden and his
deposition exhibit 42 to both Amber
please describe to the jury what's
depicted here that's a picture of my
friends and I when we were at that
London house
[Music]
um
that Johnny punched
you saw him punch this I heard it
all right let's go to 7 23 please
[Music]
move the admission of defendant 723
any objection no objection all right 7
23 redacted in evidence let the record
reflect this was shown to officer signs
and Haddon in their depositions exhibit
38 for both
Amber please describe for the jury
what's reflected
um I'm one of the it looks like a magnum
bottle of wine
um that is
empty or spilled on the floor
can you tell where that is located
um looks like it would be Penthouse five
okay
let's go to 724
move the admission of defendant 724.
no objection all right 724 with
redactions thank you and let the record
reflect this was shown to officer signs
and Haddon as their deposition exhibits
33 Amber please tell the jury what's
depicted here this is um more wine that
Johnny was spilling as he was using the
um
using the bottle he was holding as a you
know a bat of sorts
go to 725
.
we're almost done just two more
promise
with the admission of defendant 725 now
object chart 725 with redactions and let
the record reflect this was shown to
officer signs and hadn't and as
deposition exhibit 37 to their
depositions Amber please tell the jury
what's depicted here
uh more spilled wine on the floor this
looks like Penthouse five
okay and the last but not least Michelle
please defendants 726.
[Music]
uh move the admission
um
no objection okay um your honor I
believe
the jury
needs the tissue oh okay thank you [ __ ]
we will we will get a tissue
you got some thank you halusa
all right no objection 726 with
redactions thank you
all right and let the record reflect
that this one was shown to officer Heinz
and and Hadden as deposition 32 exhibit
to their depositions and Amber please
just described to the jury what's
depicted here uh more spilled wine on
the floor Penthouse three appears okay
thank you
now when the police officers were there
did either of them take you aside by
yourself and talk with you
yes which one or both
the male officer I did not have much
interaction with the female officer
asked to
said she needed to speak to me by by
myself pulled me aside we went into
Penthouse three the main Penthouse
to speak there because I had been in
Penthouse one Raquel and Josh's
apartment
up until that moment okay and then what
if anything did she ask you
uh she asked me if I would make a
statement if I would cooperate she kind
of indicated to me I don't remember if
it was a
what word she said but she kind of
gestured to my face and objection your
honor hearsay all right I think she
could if she just gesture into her face
is not yourself a statement of sustain
the objection next okay and it's also
not offered to prove the truth
okay so what happened next
I
uh
let's do this how long were you with the
officer
when she took you aside
a few minutes
um if that okay
and as a result of that did you
cooperate
no I did not but
it was my understanding that I couldn't
stop them from walking through the
apartment which is what they indicated
to me
okay and were you with them when they
walked through the apartment uh no Josh
well in I was with them at the beginning
of Penthouse three Josh uh Raquel's
partner
um took over from there and showed them
around the house
up through Penthouse three which
connects on the top floor to the
neighboring apartment Penthouse four and
then on to Penthouse five they all
connect on the top level
so Josh walked the officers through the
through the house okay and what if
anything did you say about the identity
of Mr Depp
nothing
were you asked
yes but you refused to tell them
objection leading sustain okay uh why
did you refuse to tell the police
officers Mr Depp's identity
because I did not
want them to arrest Johnny I did not
want this to happen I did not want
any of this to happen
I didn't want to get him in trouble
so I said well I can't I I just refuse
to cooperate
now after approximately how long were
the police officers there
I don't recall exactly maybe
um
I'd say less than half an hour
I really don't know exactly but they
weren't there very long at all
now after the police officers left what
did you do
um we cleaned up a bit uh because there
was broken glass and we had dogs
so we tried to clean up the mess and
especially the glass and
um
Josh Rocky Liz and I we kind of just
cleaned up and eventually
um
sat on the couch and they just tried to
comfort me
what if any knowledge did you have that
there was going to be a second set of
officers coming later that night I
didn't know about that that surprised me
when did you learn that a second set of
officers were coming to the the
penthouse that night I think I learned
about it when they were there when they
arrived
uh and we've seen the the body worn
video
um on that is there anything that you
recall outside of what was reflected on
officer Gayton gateland's uh uh body
worn video
I couldn't see much of
of what was on that video I just
uh I remember
being surprised that they were there not
really knowing why they were there I
assumed it was because I was encouraged
to make a statement by the first set of
officers especially honor hearsay
okay and I was sitting on the couch it
was uh sometime hours maybe uh Maybe
maybe between an hour two hours maybe
more I don't really recall but we had
cleaned up and we were resting and they
were comforting me when they came and
um they didn't seem to they didn't do it
the first set of officers did they um
just kind of came into the apartment
confirmed that
we that that I was okay or that we were
okay they didn't really seem to
be that concerned
um and they didn't demand to do a walk
through like the first set of officers
had
um and they left okay and what if any
cooperation did you give them
well I didn't need to I didn't really
cooperate with that I didn't talk to
them I did I don't I didn't even get up
off the couch I was speaking to them
from a a quite a bit of a distance like
between you and I and maybe more and I
didn't really say anything I just kind
of acknowledged that they entered and
that I that that was it did you provide
them with Mr Jeff's name no way
did they ask no okay
okay all right I'm going to take you to
the next day
uh May 22.
um
and I'm going to Michelle can you bring
up defendants exhibits 772
what if any efforts did Mr Depp make to
reach out to you the day after this
happened
while he he made several efforts
immediately he kind of reached out and
lashed out
um again kind of going on what seems to
be
slightly delusional thinking that just
because he saw all my friends beads out
on the countertop that it had become a
workshop or a studio for her so he
seemed angry about
you know this perception that this
display that my friend had set up was
evidence of her running some sort of
workshop and he also accused us of
having or me of having invited someone
else to live there who
who wasn't living there who's just in
the apartment when Johnny stormed in
so he just kind of lashed out and then
the tone changed and the days that
followed and let me stop you there so
I'm going to ask you to take a look at
defendant's exhibit
772 and is this a text message from Mr
Depp to you
yes it is and it's on 5 22 at 12 23 a.m
so it's early morning hours after 5 21
would that be fair
yes your honor I'm going to move the
admission of defendant 772 no objection
all right 772 and evidence with the
identifier is redacted
and publish thank you thank you your
honor
all right and uh I know you started to
talk about this Amber
um
but it says
I'm an idiot pH five is Rocky's Studio
you are Shameless you see that yes okay
was that what you were talking about
with him thinking that you're yes okay
and then uh obviously we can read that
he says I tried to make it work you just
turned more and more into a spoiled brat
all you wanted was to make me [ __ ]
miserable well I'm finally there
I'll never be able to understand how I
fell in love with you you're not her I
loved you more than anything I did
everything that I could but you never
[ __ ] loved me I was merely convenient
for you I hope our divorce goes as
quickly as possible and that it is as
painless as possible so sorry you were
as unhappy with me as you were obviously
the purity of whatever was has been gone
for a long time I will miss the moments
of beauty and Truth goodbye Amber what
the [ __ ] was I thinking I wish you all
Merit all you married the former hymn
um what if any discussions did you have
with Mr Depp about divorce that night
uh we did not
have a discussion about that uh that
evening we didn't have time he was
um
obsessed with dog poop okay that's what
he wanted to talk about
all right let's take this down and let's
go to defendants exhibit 773
now this is a text exchange between you
and Mr Depp
uh it starts with Mr Depp on 521 at 6 58
PM just saying here does that refresh
your recollection of when he arrived at
your penthouse on May 21.
uh yes okay and then the next series are
on 522 they start at 5 13.
and you're discussing talking you said
sorry I'm just leaving Amanda's birthday
now do you see that
yes I do all right and then he responds
to that correct yes all right your honor
I'd like to move the admission of
defendant 773
your honor if we could just have a
minute to review this exhibit yes ma'am
is it just this page uh no there's three
pages three pages I'm just reading
Michelle's hands
foreign
thank you
and if we could okay we've got to
published to the jury so let's go to the
top Michelle and so it starts out with
with him this is the 521 6 58 PM saying
he's there correct yeah but I think he
came in later than that took him some
time okay and then if we move up the
next one is you uh at 5 22 at 5 13 PM
correct
yes and then you say thank you and then
can we still speak and amend
what do you call of why you sent those
texts I believe we had spoken on the
phone
are they
I can't uh control this correct the
screen I I don't know it can give you
control yes maybe we should do that and
clear out my purples
I just don't know what was sent right
before this go ahead go ahead we can't
scroll she's asking to scroll okay
Michelle let's have you scroll if you
can
through just slowly
so she can read the whole thing
I
makes
[Music]
um
all right does that help refresh your
recollection uh yes I believe that
uh that I'm I believe he had apologized
to me after the phone incident I had
commitments that I had to
attend the following day on the 22nd so
the beat show I referenced I mentioned
to you I had to go to I would also had
to bring a cake to a friend's birthday
party so I had things I was I
unfortunately had to do that day
and I remember there was communication
with Johnny
um
both by phone and by text
where he was uh
telling me that he was clean that he was
sober he
um was clear mind it wasn't the monster
and that he was so sorry
um but I
um
I had already
committed to filing for divorce
and um
eventually I have to let him know that
it's not just not just saying it in the
anger in the fights that like we had
done you know both he and I did that
at times in some of our fights
especially towards the end of our
relationship and so
um I let him know that I I was
I was serious about filing this time and
that I had had enough after the after
the crushing on her here so enough okay
Overworld go ahead all right I'm going
to draw your attention to the bottom of
the page defendants exhibit 773 and this
is at 522 so this is 6 19 p.m do you see
that 522 and he says just let me know
when you have a minute and I'll give you
a call nothing I have to say you should
elicit anything but a sense of ease do
you see that yes and then he says all my
love and profound apologies
what was he apologizing for objection
calls for speculation
what was your understanding of what he
was apologizing for speculation your
honor of sustain the objection okay in
his phone call with you did he tell you
what he was apologizing for yes what did
he say he was sorry that he reacted the
way he did and he said he didn't mean to
hurt me he didn't mean
to hurt me if he really hurt me that bad
he's sorry that he just he didn't mean
to
[Music]
okay Michelle if we can go to the next
page
up to the green please
and he says here I'm sad I'm scared and
I'm broken my sweet Slim
and then he says I want you happy I have
zero harsh feelings I am clear and I am
me
what did you understand him to mean by I
am clear and I am me objection your
honor calls for speculation
okay but your honor this is that phrase
with you hold on I'll sustain that
objection
then you can ask your next question okay
do you did he use those phrases with you
during your marriage yes he did what did
Mr Depp mean when he says I'm clear and
I am me objection calls for speculation
I think I established the foundation
thank you
that he had sobered up
that he'd sobered up and he was not the
Monster again that he was him
that he was a good guy I loved
all right now I'm going to ask Michelle
if you can take that one down and bring
in 771 which has already been admitted
now those text exchanges were
in the six o'clock to almost seven
o'clock range
and here it's 5 22 it's now 8 o'clock
correct yes and he's telling you sorry
if a bit please know that my hurt
towards you is over
my apologies are Eternal and belong to
you solid do you see that
yes okay
and was it your understanding he was
apologizing again objection your honor
calls for speculation all right I'll
sustain the objection okay
was there anything else he would have
been apologizing for that he had done
objection calls for speculation sustain
the objection
so tell the jury how you felt in that
week May 22 through May 27 and what you
decided to do
uh at the time it felt like the hardest
thing I've ever had to do
I had worked so hard
to try to make this relationship work
I went to therapy and went to Al-Anon I
got help I read books I did everything I
could possibly do and it didn't work
and um
I find I was I was conflicted to answer
your question I was conflicted I knew
after he threw the phone at my face that
after all that that month of not seeing
each other not getting better not
getting clean and sober there wasn't
even
I didn't you know the the
the
oh it was falling apart and I knew I had
I knew I had to leave him I knew I I
wouldn't
I knew I wouldn't survive it if I didn't
so
I made the decision to
to file for divorce
it's hard because um
you know I love Johnny so much
I loved him so much
and why did you file for divorce
divorce because I knew if I didn't
that I knew if I didn't I'd likely not
literally survive
like Britain
something so scared that it was gonna
end
really badly for me
and I am
really didn't want to leave him
I loved him
so much
I wouldn't have done anything but I I
couldn't
I couldn't do that one thing I couldn't
stay
the
the promise and the hope that I had I
had become less and less regular and
more and more rare the monster had been
this thing that was now the normal and
not the exception
the violence was now normal and not the
exception and
so uh
a little hard
it was so hard but I knew I had to do it
again
I believe he wouldn't have
taken it too far
I wouldn't be here
why did you ask for a domestic violence
temporary restraining order
I wanted to change my locks
I wanted to change my locks
I wanted a good night's sleep
security
would always let him into the house no
matter what I asked them no matter when
I when I begged them to let me know when
he was coming over no matter how much I
begged him not to let him in when he was
mad or drunk or high
and I just I couldn't sleep I wake up in
a panic
I was losing hair
I was losing weight
I got really sick
I had shingles I couldn't sleep I'd wake
up in a panic attack
I had panic attacks all the time
I was falling apart
and
I was scared and
I'm very conflicted because
the person I was scared of is also the
person I was in love with
really really tricky
and I was thinking one step at a time
you know I was thinking
very myopically I wanted just to get
a good night rest a good night's sleep I
just wanted to change my locks
I thought it'd be healthier if I got
some sleep and I could think about what
to do and how to handle this
if I just could sleep and
when I did I realized
that that wasn't enough
that he could get in anyway
that the building wasn't going to stop
him from getting a locksmith and coming
in I knew that he would
do what he wanted objection honor calls
for speculation
thank you all right next
okay
so did Mr debb show up for the hearing
on the DVT Ro
no he didn't did you yes I did okay and
why did you show up because I had to
provide testimony for why I needed a
restraining order
what if any warning
did you give Mr Depp about obtaining the
DV tro
we gave him warning
my counsel and his Council were in
communication and we let them know we
had to it was mandatory
it's my understanding of it I'm not a
lawyer
was there any confusion surrounding
whether Mr Depp was going to file suit
as well
objection honor
cultural speculation lack of foundation
also say it is the foundation
did you have
to whether Mr
so I um I filed for divorce uh on the
23rd I believe and I thought
that when I went in that Tuesday we or
when we filed for it remarkably it
managed to stay under the radar you know
these filings are not private you can't
make them private in California
and remarkably it had flown under the
radar
no one picked up on the fact that I had
filed and
uh as limited as it sounds now I just
wanted as much privacy as we could have
you know one day at a time I wanted as
much privacy as we could possibly get
and the filing had been missed by TMZ
and you know these Paparazzi outlets and
stuff
but um between the communications
between our Council I realized that
Johnny was going to file and rejection
hearsay
uh I'll sustain the objection
um
saying what the council said what were
you what was your understanding and what
was your concern objection hearsay
sustain the objection
all right well let's move on let's
Michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 800 please
move the admission of defendants exhibit
800 any objection no objection your
honor all right 800 in evidence
Amber can you describe for the jury what
this picture is
it's a picture of my face while I'm
sitting at the courthouse
and were you wearing any makeup
I was wearing nothing not a stitch of
makeup
Michelle can you bring up 801 please
move the admission of 801 no objection
801 in evidence publish
an Amber if you can tell the jury what
this is
it's me while I was uh
obtaining my restraining order
to be in the courthouse okay and and
what if anything did you do while you
were at the courthouse
did you testify oh I provided testimony
and sat there and cried
and did you obtain a domestic violence
restraining order I did uh the court
granted me a restraining order at that
time
when you left the courthouse
what did you experience
I walked into the courthouse it was
quiet first thing in the morning
uh no one knew about my divorce so
I thought it was going to stay that way
and I walked out to a c
of Paparazzi and cameras
photographers
it was I to that point hadn't I mean at
that point in my life had never seen so
many
photographers and they just surrounded
me as I walked out of that courthouse
and
screamed at me screamed horrible things
at me
I'm gonna take you just for a moment to
make up and then we'll that would happen
yeah the breaking point after the makeup
I said that you didn't testify you uh
didn't wear any makeup that day we've
heard all kinds of things about makeup
in this case could you please tell the
jury what your regular routine was with
respect to makeup
uh yes I get up and wash my face like
most of us and I put on right away a
moisturizer that has tinted foundation
in it
and then I put another foundation on
because it has sunblock in it I have a
skin condition that my skin reacts to
the sun in a bad way
so I have to I have to wear sunscreen or
sunblock every day anyway so I put on
both of those I put on concealer
uh and I I do that before I leave my
bathroom in the morning
that's obviously if I don't have a
bruise now when you had bruises or cuts
of any nature what would you do
about those would you try to cover them
up would you try to just leave them
showing what would you do objectiana
leading yeah
uh well I'm a typical I am typically
photographed in La when I leave the
house uh Paparazzi type of photograph so
I always I'm you know somewhat aware of
that anyway
um and no one woman no woman wants to
walk around with a bruise on her face
uh so if I do have a bruise uh on my
face or someplace visible you know the
main thing you have to ice right away to
reduce swelling because no amount of
makeup can can fix swelling but it's
very manageable if you ice it really
soon
arnica is also a great remedy arnica
cream and then if you want to cover up a
bruise you obviously put Foundation
First concealer and then on top of that
I used a like a bruise kit not a bruise
kit it's a theater makeup kit a color
correction kit but I use I called it my
bruise kit and Lobby I use this I think
in opening statement and it's defendants
exhibit you could buy the microphone
please just we can hear it um there you
go may I approach uh the witness to
that's what you could show the council
uh yeah this is what I was talking about
as a color correction kit this is not
obviously the exact one I used to carry
but I used to carry it with me all the
time sometimes this pink is sometimes a
little bit more purple of a hue and
sometimes the kids are three colors you
can get them in three or four colors
sometimes they have even more but the
idea is that you want to counteract
whatever color you're working with on
the bruise so the first day of bruising
and well the immediate is red red is
what shows up right away so you want to
go with the opposite on the color wheel
by dabbing on a bit of the green or
something to counteract thread after a
day or two you get more purple in a
bruise so
you'd obviously have to go with more of
the red tones or the orange tones here
um day two for me was always the
trickiest because
um
day two just I feel like well day one
and day two are hardest for me because
that's when you get the most blues and
purples and you have to
deal with the sensitivity bruises don't
like to be touched that's the whole
point so that's the trickiest part but
after a few days that becomes more of a
that blue becomes more of a a brown
yellowish Browns like a you know five
seven days in becomes more of a yellow
green
uh and then Fades into a brown and then
into your skin
and you whatever color you're working
with in the bruise you want to go
opposite color on the color wheel
so
the opposite I mean so in the first
couple of days when you have more of the
typical bruise color the blues and and
the purples
you want to go more of the orange uh on
the on the color wheel as opposed to the
greens that you start with and then it
move it progresses from there I also
noticed that
um bruising on your face uh tends to
heal a lot faster than at least for me
it was faster healing than bruises on my
body or at least it seemed like that to
me
and a nose is pretty much
unrecognizable after a day or two
depending on how much you ice it lips
are the hardest because they crack and
bleed of course uh but that's easy to
hide with lipstick if you're a woman or
you know if you wear a lipstick I
suppose
I know we heard some testimony of people
uh in the week of May 21st to 27th uh
saying that you didn't wear a stitch of
makeup was that true objection hearsay
overall
uh they just don't know what they're
talking about I always wear makeup
you always wear makeup I mean it's part
of my bathroom routine in the morning
you know wash my face I put on
moisturizer my moisturizer has tinted
foundation in it and I'm certainly not
going to walk around La
with bruises on my face
okay
all right ladies and Gentlemen let's go
ahead and take our lunch recess at this
time again do not do any outside
research and not discuss the case with
anybody and we'll see you in an hour
okay thank you
court is still in session so please be
quiet in the gallery thank you
all right
and again miss heard since you're still
under uh under oath and testifying you
cannot discuss this case and to include
with your attorneys okay and your
testimony all right let's come back then
at 1 40. okay all right thank you
all right are we ready for the jury oh
we have things okay
yes
what do we have
okay we're ready for the jury
foreign
thank you seated all right your next
question yeah I'd like to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 155
okay that's the uh the makeup palette oh
okay any objection to that no objection
all right 155 in evidence do we have it
I think it's there we had pictures for
all right thank you all right 155
okay okay yes ma'am thank your honor
Michelle uh can you bring up but dep
exhibit number 357 B is in boy
plaintiff's exhibit and it is a tape
recording from June 2016.
the time stamps are 4 colon 47 to 7
colon 52.
all right is that in evidence yet I'm
going to move the admission okay so was
that going to be for the whole 357 or is
that 357 a or is that that's just B B I
have that as a b as in boy I think there
was a proportion okay 357 B any
objection to 357 B
know your honor all right 357 be in
evidence thank you
how are you the briefing fact is like
taking private
profile that's not the move that one
that other that the other party has to
make okay it's just not okay and you get
what you're a kingdom okay and then
within five minutes
you just do the math yourself without
any other thing in the advice very clear
okay and I I don't know if you knew that
no I didn't know that and and if that's
the case I'll I'll I'll I'll acknowledge
it
you know
um and if you say you're approving then
I'll acknowledge it but it doesn't shock
me the
game yeah it can make sense the journey
would do something like that it doesn't
you know
um yeah it doesn't Shock Me
but I'm telling you now
we go if I file if they file the [ __ ]
papers tomorrow
which means like the [ __ ] I got to file
before we go to court on Friday
if they fly those papers
first of all
it's
very bad
for both of us okay
come on here and everything is bad for
you trust me no you're you're what
you're saying you you got to do
something to protect yourself which
means throwing me under the bus for the
some video about me being not not me I
have to respond immediately we mean I'll
have to go and pursue the no I said
pursue the whole course of action
because here's what you don't understand
if if we do this and if well basically
we'll know because my I call my lawyers
why aren't we negotiating more what is
going on why where are we and they're
like everything you've done in our court
no they won't settle your agents want
your your lawyers won't settle baby I'm
telling you
we want comedians we even have immediate
we even found mediators and and
everything but that was all worked out
so the thing that Lord even agreed to
was she did not want to agree to a
mutual gag order and that's the problem
that she doesn't want the gag order why
Johnny
why
wouldn't she why didn't she want both
parties to not talk about this in the
Press but he was just talking about pets
not even talking about court okay let's
see what another let me get on that
right now I'll [ __ ] get on it right
now
and oh and I'll I'll get a message back
to you somehow just just uh you know uh
but I'll get i'll get on it right now
I just want you to know I I'm not doing
anything and have not been doing any
moves let's look it up timeline nothing
was on the office everything's been in
his move because I'm being called a liar
and a gold digger and I'm not lying
about
and I am not after a dime of your money
and
do you remember when you had this
discussion with Mr death
yes when was that I believe that was
um June of 2016 so after
the divorce uh what we saw the
restraining order
objection calls for speculation
asking her I haven't overruled
uh I was
I was trying to
[Music]
um
I was trying to get Johnny to stop the
smear campaign
um objection your honor hearsay
lack of foundation
what if any discussion did you have with
him about a smear campaign Johnny told
me that he would ruin me that no one
would ever touch me meaning in
professionally no one would ever work
with me again
uh that I'd never work again that I'd be
selling depends is what he said
uh
and that he had ruined my career
and he refused to
um
not engage with up until that point he
refused to not engage with the Press by
leaking objections calls for speculation
how is that speculation I I
this is what he's telling her correct
right okay all right I'll overruled the
objection
and up until that point
um I was trying to
you know uh get him to call the dogs off
call it off because it was um
it was forcing me into position where he
was calling me a liar and he was forcing
me to prove it and I knew that wasn't
going to be good for him and I I kept
saying don't make me
don't make me prove it I don't want to
but he was calling me a liar and having
a really sophisticated very very well
paid very sophisticated PR uh machine
it's actually going over class for
speculation I'm not sustain the
objection I'll move on um let's go to
deaf exhibit that's playing this exhibit
357c
that's 12 colon 30 to 16 colon 30.
remove the admission
any objection
no objection all right 357c in evidence
all right
all right Michelle if you complain
about me throwing you under the bus you
know what it would be it would be
released through documented people
coming on the record and having the
protection to do so that haven't had yet
it would be eyewitness statement it
would be
advocate
okay and it would be three years
and it would be
unbelievable
unbelievable
um to imagine that either I mean a
secret fake Club will be I've had um
fight club or that I have been plotting
to do this for the you know for three
three and well he
and documenting it just saving it up for
the right time when I'm not asking for
any money have nothing Financial to gain
from it but no one is going to believe
that no one is going to believe that one
of the two Alternatives either I'm in a
fight club
I do all these years where I have
cooperating text messages between people
that match those dates of those
timestamps validated photos
of
of I would either cooperation between
people hearing us or coverage of next
day you know witnessing text message to
Kevin him responding or you know the
kind of stuff like between uh me and
people
it is a plan I'm gonna put makeup on
myself and take pictures throughout the
years and just sit on it for years that
that
while having this like imaginary Life
One parallel to it you understand that I
the pictures I have not but text
messages to my mom back and forth
you know and text messages between say
Raquel and my mom or my return
or you know um between my two friends or
there's a text message where I tell Jody
the night before I had that James Corden
Knife Show
thing well I say hey jerky I'm not an
accident
um I think I may have I have a question
I may have a busted nose and and
um people like eyes tomorrow because
I don't
know
[Music]
I don't know
I'm fixing it um
you know
and things like that it doesn't matter
there is nothing there
nothing
and I've got all of that we'll see me
throwing you understand that will be
evidence in this
geez it will be criminal as well because
I cannot go on signing and file
without firing a big state ment first
and the only reason
that's against me by the way every day
the only reason I won't do it I haven't
done it
I don't want to hurt you and that means
it goes out of my hands and every yeah
the third party guy uh third-party
prosecutor comes and um and a criminal
lawyer come and they went like the
problem is during commute like your
biggest struggle is that
it's such a it's a
most solid evidence
the domestic violence we've ever seen
and if you get this over example present
any part of it
they look him and I felt like
I
I didn't
ask for you
I can't even understand
even accept any sort of victim Dome ever
can you please explain what the context
of this was
I was
begging Johnny to not make me prove
what I've had to sit on the stand in
front of all of you and prove
and talk about
I was begging not to do this and have to
sit where I'm sitting today
I didn't want this
I don't want to be here I didn't want to
be there then
and I was trying to point out
something to somebody who I thought did
not have a firm grasp on reality Jackson
calls for speculation
I was trying to point out
how absurd
I'm sorry it would be
for him to keep making me
prove this by calling me a liar I was
trying to get him to not call me a liar
because everything that I had said today
and everything I said to date now is the
truth
and I was begging him not to make me
prove it that there were photos that
there were witnesses that there was my
testimony
there were years of me with injuries
on the dates where we were fighting and
they were documented I mean pictures
from 2012.
so I was trying to say to him either
you'd suppose that people would rather
believe this is a hoax
elaborate well orchestrated year-long
campaign for what
or that
what it just seemed crazy
and I thought no one was advising him in
his best interest I thought no one was
telling him the truth
I know he's surrounded by yes men and I
thought nobody was saying to Johnny this
is crazy don't do this
and I didn't want to hurt him I didn't
want to hurt him I loved him I loved him
so much
that's why I'm explaining to him why I
didn't file criminal charges I didn't
file a police report even though it was
being used against me I didn't want this
to go to a prosecutor I didn't want this
to
Hurt Johnny
I don't want this to hurt John
Michelle can you bring up Deb exhibit
357 d as in David
and that is 17 colon 25 to 17 colon 37.
I'm going to move the admission your
honor all right objection all right
all right and evidence 337d
baby
gold digger baby every morning baby
remember I didn't call you those things
I didn't call yourself
I'm gonna go on now to uh can we go to
plaintiff's exhibit 357 e
and this is 21 colon 47 to 22 colon 37.
I'm going to move the admission you're
on any objection no objection 357e thank
you
thank you and you're stronger
that you can walk your own finger I I am
not trying to attack you here I'm just
trying to point out the fact of why I
said call 9-1-1 because
[Music]
crazy in the past and I
thought
I mean stop
this madness before
Oh my God and I never think about myself
that way I never defend myself that way
I never see myself as a victim you know
all right yeah and I
I when they came I did not cooperate
with them it has been unit against me
not by the media by your side who
and what are you referring to there
foreign
don't want to call myself a victim I
don't like to think of myself as a
victim and I don't want him to think I'm
attacking him or blaming him
I'm pointing out I didn't cooperate with
the police that I didn't
want to get him in trouble
but I didn't want to hurt him I don't
want anything from him just don't call
me a liar it's all I said just don't
call me a liar
just don't say this isn't real
because I'm the walking proof of it
I'm gonna ask to bring up plaintiff's
exhibit death exhibit 357 f as in Frank
24 colon 04 to 24 colon 48 and move the
admission all right a objection no
objection all right 357 f
M oh yeah my integrity and that
unfortunate thing
what about mine it's got further what
about mine
literally in words I'm out of my mouth
every step of the way I have said to
them the thing is they're hurting Johnny
by this because every time that they
call me a liar or the distance
of your security guards
regarding they never thought of use
happening this
big daughter's little by the way
have sent me
multiple times
and
what are you talking about there Amber
that even though
Johnny told me
that his guards would say whatever he
needed them to say that they were the
same guards who had told me that I would
lose weight hearsay all right it's the
same objection it came in through the
tape so that's all right we're fine
um
thank you
Michelle can you bring up Dev exhibit
357 G plaintiffs 357 G and it's 26
colon 0 0 to 26 colon 28.
foreign
too you know
I can talk about all of this do you
believe all this out
do you believe
you believe you believe I'm an abuser
you believe I'm an abuser
referring to with the May December and
April
just listing some of the times in which
he beat me up
and that he knew about
so I'm going to take you now fast
forward into the July 2016 time frame
there was a mediation that came about
during that time
what if any intent did you have to
reconcile with Mr debb at the time of
the mediation
I I wanted there to be no animosity I
wanted to minimize animosity I wanted to
reconcile in the that way I didn't want
to get back together with him that makes
sense
foreign
can you just briefly describe what
transpired during the July mediation
I
even though I had a tro and I wanted to
move on with my life the campaign I
mentioned earlier the smear campaign the
article after article the founding me
the you know leaking
fake objection you're on or
non-responsive all right I stained the
objection okay
please explain what I was
meeting with him about is because he
you know put these things out in the
media it seemed like objection your
honor culture speculation lack of
foundation
all right did Mr Deb discuss with you
that he was putting these out in the
media protection leading overruled I
love it yes
please explain
he told me he would tell his team to
back off and to
to yeah to back off effectively if I
agreed to do certain things one of which
you know there was he wanted me to
um like drop charges he wanted or some
version of that he wanted me to um get
back together with him and go on tour
with him in the tour bus he wanted me to
do certain things that I thought were
impossible and that would definitely go
against
all of all of
you know
everything that I stood for and and had
earned in getting my my tro getting my
restraining order and moving on but I
had to break the tro in order to beg him
to stop the machine the press machine
because I was feeling like I couldn't
live my life I was being dropped from
opportunity commercial opportunities
people were turning on me a campaign I
shot dropped me I mean it was just I had
never been inundated with that much
press every single day me and my family
were an every witness anyone who even
indirectly supported me got bombarded
and the action campaign calls for
speculation
like a foundation I'll stay in just the
last the last part of that all right
next question okay
um we heard Christian Carino testify
earlier can you describe to the jury who
what your relationship is it was with
Christian Carino
he was my commercial agent meaning he
handled things like campaigns uh for a
short amount of time and then uh became
Johnny's agent around the time of the
divorce
he was a kind of mutual friend at the
time between Johnny and I and so he
helped us kind of negotiate or mediate a
time where we could meet and my goal in
that was to just beg Johnny to stop
doing this objection non-responsive
overruled that's right what if any
desire did you have to return to Mr Depp
after the divorce none okay
now you heard Mr White testify that he
engaged in negotiations with you during
the settlement process of the divorce
what if any discussions did you have
with Mr White
none I the first time I saw him was
on on the testimony screen in the UK
during the UK trial I've never spoken to
him so he didn't negotiate Your
settlement no he did not
what was important to you in the divorce
negotiations
the the
statement that was it the statement
I wanted a mutual statement and I wanted
him to call the you know get the press
out of this
make a statement
and and and in that statement
clear my name I wanted to clear my name
it's all I have I
I you know I I said this to him too and
you know he knew this
all I have is my name I come from
nothing all I have is my Integrity all I
have is my name
and that's exactly what he promised to
take from me
why did you agree there except seven
million dollars it's a big settlement I
didn't care about the money I was told
if I didn't agree to a number
that it could be overturned that this
would never actually it would never get
complete it would never settle objection
here
what was your understanding that if I
didn't agree to a number it would be
overturned so I took
far less than what they were offering
and what I was entitled to
and why did you donate it to charity
I promised the entirety of it to charity
because I was never interested in
Johnny's money
and in the divorce
I just wanted my safety I wanted to move
on for my life I wanted my future and
then he started compromising that
calling me a liar making it impossible
for me to move on
by doing so
so that I wanted the truth I wanted him
to clear my name and to leave me alone
I've been saying that since 2016.
so why did you donate 3.5 to Children's
Hospital and 3.5 to ACLU
well I pledged the first half or 3.5 to
children's hospital because I've been
working there as a volunteer for well
over a decade
I knew the facility Well I'd worked
there with another non-profit is how I
got affiliated with them and I knew they
could use the resources I was familiar
with it
and what about the ACLU uh and then ACLU
because I was a supporter because I
believed in the work that we're doing I
believed that they were
doing good work for people who deserved
it
why did you make the donations over a
period of time as opposed to just a lump
sum
um two two reasons the short of it is
because I was receiving the settlement
and installments I was receiving the
installments over time
second of all I could get the tax
benefit of paying overtime you know with
my understanding that's how you pay
these like large sums you paid over time
did you make any payments towards these
donations I did
uh
approximately how much
I um allowed for the first installment
which is a hundred thousand um to each
that came straight from Johnny in 2016.
I followed up with uh 350 000 uh that
year
um 2016 uh 2018 I did another oh and I
also donated to 250 000 to Art of
Elysium which is the affiliate I was
just speaking about
um that does the work in the Children's
Hospital
it was not going to count towards my
overall pledge but I did that too and
then I did another donation to you each
in 2018.
and then Johnny sent me 2019.
before we get to that uh did anyone make
donations to the children's hospital or
ACLU on your behalf during that time
period yes Elon also Elon who was my
boyfriend at the time had his own
charitable contributions that he had
that he made and he made 500 000 to both
in my honor in my name in 2017 I believe
and have you completely fulfilled your
donations to the ACLU and the Children's
Hospital I have not yet and why not
because Johnny sued me for 50 million
dollars in March of 2019.
and I have spent over six million
objection Runner
this is a motion and Lemony did that
part was supposed to come in once you
come forward let's take a look
foreign
foreign
so going back to that then could you
afford to continue making payments to
the ACLU and Children's Hospital
no okay what if any intention do you
have to fulfill your pledges and
donations to these organizations I still
fully intend to honor all of my pledges
I would love for him to stop suing me so
I can
what if any deadlines are there on your
pledges and donations to the ACLU or the
Children's Hospital there are none
they understand
now let's uh let's go to defendant's
exhibit 1458 which is already admitted
now I'm going to just direct your
attention to paragraph 27 where it says
neither party has made false accusations
for financial gain there was never any
intent of physical or emotional harm
Amber Wishes the best for Johnny in the
future what if any significance did that
have to you
that was everything to me that was what
that was the most important thing in in
the separation agreement between us is
that he acknowledged
that
I hadn't made a single false claim that
my allegations were not false I thought
that just because he signed his name to
it he'd honor it I mean
he signed his name to it and I thought
it would mean something
he acknowledges that I never did it I
mean I never made a false claim and I
didn't do it for financial gain and
that's what I was being called at the
time a gold digger and a liar
thank you
we can take this down Michelle and I'm
going to now take you to post divorce
and your career please describe for the
jury
how your career evolved after the
divorce which I think was Final in
February 2017.
I
I had to fight really hard to keep my
career I
you know in after I got my tro I lost
opportunities I got canceled from jobs I
got dropped from campaign I'd shot I um
was told I was going to be dropped from
objection honor hearsay
the same objection I fought to keep my
job in um in a movie opportunity the
biggest movie opportunity I had to date
which was what uh it was Justice League
um with the option to become Aquaman it
later became Aquaman
um but I had to fight really hard to
stay even Injustice League because that
was right around the time of the divorce
can you tell the jury what Justice
League was and what your role was in
that it is a superhero uh franchise DC
action film
and it introduced my character
and it provided the base for the Aquaman
spin-off that followed it but that was
not a reality at the time of shooting
Justice League
and then you you were able to be an
Aquaman is that correct
yes I
I kind of showed up to work months early
and stayed really late
to fight to keep the job I managed to
keep it
and manage slowly to kind of to gain
through this kind of hard work and
Goodwill I was able to Foster I was able
to keep and make other jobs and
eventually made a movie called Aquaman
and Aquaman was very successful I think
it was the most successful DC film
um by its release and we you know I was
I was getting my
career back even though it was you know
it took a major hit when I when I got my
restraining order against Johnny
so let's talk about Aquaman for a moment
I think you said it was the highest
grossing film of DC films is that
correct yes okay when did that come out
December of 2018.
and what was your role in Aquaman
Aquaman I play Mira
and was that a lead role uh yes it is
one of the leading roles it's the female
lead opposite Jason momoa's character of
Aquaman okay so you were his
mate
you could say that yes I was his
um love interest the the female I was a
female lead of the movie
so in December of 2018 as Aquaman's
coming out why did you agree to
participate in the op-ed
well because I
believed in some of the causes that the
op-ed was seeking to advance uh there
were there was a lot of attention and
energy around
um
gender-based issues gender-based
violence issues in general I had just
recently become an ambassador for the
ACLU I was proud of that ambassadorship
and I was looking forward to the
opportunity to lend my voice to what I
thought was a great cause which is just
a conversation around
women's issues and gendered issues that
I think the whole country was having at
that time you know quite a political
conversation and cultural conversation
at the time and I was
happy to lend my voice if I could
who drafted the first draft of the op-ed
the ACLU
did you initially want to include Mr
Depp by name or reference no
what were you trying to accomplish by
the op-ed
I was trying to raise awareness around
some of the issues that I just mentioned
there were some legislative reform uh
Title IX being one of them uh and there
was just a greater cultural conversation
being had around
gender issues and um
and I was happy to weigh in
um on what I saw as a the you know
unique
phenomena that women
typically women experience in our
culture when they come forward against
somebody more powerful
uh when they speak up about
gender-based violence and
I thought I could lend my voice to that
conversation I thought I had something
to say about that
were you trying to boost your sales for
Aquaman since it was coming out in that
same time frame
uh
it doesn't work like that I don't think
any op-ed uh I mean I
a major emotion picture or major
franchise like that is not aided by the
publication of a an op-ed in the
Washington Post I'll put it that way but
the other way around can be said you
know I was
wanting to lend my name at that specific
time
um to potentially Advance the causes
within the op-ed
because of your success as Mira with
Aquaman yeah just the publicity of the
movie and the success of the movie would
hopefully
um and best case scenario
um only add and lend itself uh to
would lend attention to the issues that
the op-ed aimed to address
op-ed to put your name to it
I sought the advice of my attorney
and why did you do that
well because I
you know I didn't want to get into any
sort of legal issue
um I didn't want to have any sort of
legal problems
um
for for talking about what happens to
women when or people when they come
forward and speak about
these sorts of issues especially when
they come forward against someone more
powerful than them and that backlash the
retaliation that people face when they
come forward
is exactly what I was writing about and
I didn't want Johnny to retaliate
against me
and quite literally prove my point
yeah
and so who was the council that you
hired to review the op-ed
uh his name was Eric George
where's he located uh Los Angeles
California how did you know Eric George
uh Eric George is the attorney who
represented me uh in a different
litigation against those produ the
producers of London Fields the movie I
mentioned earlier about having a body
double and sex scene that I didn't
approve of what was your understanding
of Eric George's experience and skills
to be able to review that op-ed for you
in the context of of your concern
objection speculation I'm asking her
understanding I'll sustain the objection
yeah next question
did you have knowledge of Eric George's
abilities at that time I did I thought
he had an excellent reputation and would
give me great advice
and what if any experience what was your
experience with them in representing you
earlier
thought it was a fantastic attorney very
smart and I trusted him
without uh going into the content of it
what if any
of Eric George's advice did you follow
in the context of the op-ed
I took all of his advice
I made all the edits he suggested I took
all of his advice
and what if any of Eric George's advice
did you ignore
none I mean he's my lawyer I listen to
him okay
going to ask you if we can pull up
Michelle plaintiff's exhibit one
foreign
version of the op-ed and it has this
title Amber Heard I spoke up against
sexual violence and faced our culture's
wrath this that has to change what if
any role did you play in this title
none
what if any role to your knowledge did
the ACLU play in this title none to my
knowledge okay are these exact words
anywhere in the article
no
no they're not
when did you first become aware of this
title being included in the online
version of the op-ed
I think in this litigation is a first
time I realized that
I'm going to now ask Michelle can you
bring up plaintiff's Exhibit 2
this has also already been invented into
evidence here yes ma'am um
and this is the on the the paper version
if you will of the Washington Post uh
with your editorial and if you go to the
second page
this one has a title A transformative
moment for women what if any role did
you play in that title
I didn't okay
okay
now do you recall seeing this version
the newspaper version at the time yes
this is the version I saw I'm very proud
of it I had it framed
you had the newspaper version not the
only I didn't I had the newspaper framed
okay
to turn to and Michelle can we pull up
plaintiff's exhibit number three
and do you recognize this document
um
yes okay you're gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna move to admit plaintiff's exhibit
number three into evidence any objection
no objection all right three in evidence
if we can publish it to the jury thank
you
no is it fair to say this is a tweet
yes it is and can you explain to the
jury what a tweet is for those who are
not as social media oriented
a tweet is a
a posting on a social media Network
called Twitter
okay
now did you send this tweet
I think so I must have okay and what if
any control did you have over whether
the title given to the op-ed online was
included in the tweet
you don't have can you don't have
control when you're retweeting something
it you I mean it's my experience that
you don't control a title when you're
retweeting something you don't get a
chance to re-editorialize someone else's
title
and and at the time you sent this tweet
did you did do you remember even
noticing that title I do not I don't I
don't think I even realized it have you
ever typed the words
from that title
no I have not
now I'm going to ask you let's go back
to number two plaintiffs two
I'm going to go
I'm going to ask you
what if anything in this op-ed was
incorrect
nothing
every word of it is true
and I'm going to direct your attention
specifically and if we can
blow this up just a touch
and move up just a touch Michelle if you
can so we get to then two years ago
then two years ago I became a public
figure representing domestic abuse and I
felt the full force of our culture's
wrath for women who speak out
was this true or false
true okay what if any thing did you do
about speaking up about domestic abuse
two years earlier
well I went and got a restraining order
against my then husband and walked out
to a sea of media and endured to that
point two years of
vitriol from the media and from
Johnny Depp supporters
in retaliation for having done so
and I guess you really answering my next
question which is and I felt the full
force of our culture's wrath for for
women who speak out is that what you
were referring to for that next yes
because at the time I thought it
couldn't be worse I
uh obviously now from where I sit today
no it got a lot it gets a lot a lot
worse
and then Michelle if we can move this up
a little bit further
well actually that's perfect Michelle
then I don't have to use my purple again
then you said I had the rare vantage
point of seeing in real time how
institutions protect men accused of
abuse is this true or false
true okay okay and explain to me what
you meant uh by that and how that was
true for you
I got a restraining order I
had to prove to a judge that I needed
one I had a bruise on my face I got a
restraining order I showed pictures I
had
proof and yet everyone
[Music]
the media the the studios that you know
both Johnny and I worked for they were
ready to support him they made
statements in support of him they were
ready to fire me yeah
all right I'll sustain the objection um
what if anything did you witness with
respect to institutions meaning the
people that we work for the institutions
we work for the studios we work for
decision makers in my industry
filmmakers and and and and and powerful
people and decision makers within my
industry whom I had not ever even met
who didn't know anything about what
happened behind closed doors in The
Marriage of Johnny and I were making
comments about me statements about me
every I was dropped from campaigns I it
was hard for me to work I was harassed
I'm harassed on a daily basis death
threats
and just the
um the fact that that wasn't uh there
was no parody uh you know the the studio
and um these decision makers and such
were so ready to support him and
eager to to objection honor hearsay yeah
sustain the objection all right
so what if any ill will or bad
intentions did you have or intend
against Mr Depp by assisting in writing
giving your name to this op-ed and in
publishing it
none it's not about Johnny
the only one who thought it was about
Johnny's Johnny
it's about me it's about what happened
to me after Johnny it's about what
happened to me after I escaped my
marriage it was about me and my life and
what I endured once
I moved on and got a tro and moved on
with my life it was about what happened
to me after the only one who made it
about him ironically is Johnny
I'm going to um we can take that down
Michelle I'm going to turn to something
about electronics and transparency
Pat you've testified about and we've
seen photographs and audio recordings
and text messages emails Etc what if
anything have you done to cooperate in
the authentic
authentication of all of these things
objection your honor
may we approach sure
thank you
all right I'm going to turn to your
counter claim you have made a counter
claim against Mr Depp in this case
correct that's correct and it's based on
three statements that Mr Mr Adam Waldman
Mr Debb's attorney made correct yes okay
um I'm going to ask uh if you can pull
up defendants exhibit 245 but Joanna I'm
going to ask
it's already an Evidence if I may
approach if we may approach this real
quickly because I think we can move this
along faster if we do this ahead of time
okay we're gonna start by bringing up
defendants 12 45
all right and moving that into evidence
no objection 12 45 in evidence thank you
your honor
and this is an article that was in The
Daily Mail
on 8 April
2020
. appreciate that
and then Michelle if you can move that
to the next page and
perfect
it says
Adam Waldman Depp's lawyer said
afterwards Amber Heard and her friends
in the media use fake sexual violence
allegations as both a sword and a shield
depending on their needs they have
selected some of her sexual violence
hoax facts as the sword inflicting them
on the public and Mr Depp do you see
that
yes I do is this a true or false
statement
false
and why is it false well
you have to use
to use what I've lived through and and
and and and what I've survived at
calling it fake
saying that that I'm I'm harming
Johnny with this I'm harming the public
with this
this is what I've lived through and to
to say that it's a hoax that these
aren't even real things
I I mean
after everything I've I've lived through
and survived and also I hadn't even
spoken about the sexual abuse within my
marriage I hadn't
I had been protective of that I didn't
want to talk about that ever
Adam Waldman was
the one who put that out in the world
is remarkable as that is I hadn't I I
protected that
I had to go to another country to give
testimony and thankfully they allowed me
to do so with confidentiality and some
protection
and then Johnny through his lawyer
not only uses that against me but says
it's a hoax
thank you now I'm going to ask if we can
bring up and it's going to be 12 46 a
and I think I'm moving this out evidence
as well there's no objections to 1246
A's and evidence you can push
and this is
an article that was published on the
28th of April 2020
and Michelle if we can
thank you
and this one says Depp's lawyer Adam
Waldman said
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set Mr Depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt didn't do the
trick he told dailymail.com
and let's keep going
so Amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and a publicist
and then placed a second call to 9-1-1
do you see that yes is that true or
false
couldn't be more false and why is that
every part of it is false I
I didn't call 9-1-1
I didn't call the police I refused to
cooperate with them to protect Johnny I
protected Johnny
I didn't call them once and I didn't
call them twice I didn't rough up the
place I cleaned up the place I didn't
even know the second cops were coming
if I wanted to get something from him I
wanted to hoax Johnny why wouldn't I
cooperate with the police wouldn't I say
something to the police
when I do more damage to the house and
then just knock over the things that you
saw pictures of it makes no sense and to
do it in online when there's no fact
checking there's no authorities there's
no one able to you know I can't respond
I can't
I can't fight this and use these sorts
of media leaks and these comments to
re-echo over and over and over again
online with a network of people that are
intent on helping Johnny through a
sophisticated PR machine attractions
hearsay speculation sustain the
objection next question
all right and so what in fact uh did you
do that night
I
cleaned up
protected Johnny
I refuse to cooperate with the police
like so many other people do
I tried really hard to keep it private
even after that even when I was
committed to filing for a divorce
I tried to protect trani I tried to
protect the history of what we had I
tried to protect him
and did the opposite
and I didn't I didn't even have a lawyer
I didn't call my publicist
I I called my contract attorney to get
me another lawyer who could give me
advice on how to protect Johnny
every bit of this
was to protect Johnny and to protect the
secret that I had fought really hard to
keep for nearly five years
which was the behind closed doors
things were not what it looked like
okay Michelle can you take this one down
and go to defendants 1247 please and
urinal move the admission all right I
know there's no objection 12 47 in
evidence
and Amber this is another daily a mail
online and this is published
on 24 June updated on 25 June 2020.
and then if we can go
further
and this one says
Depp's attorney Adam Waldman said we
have reached the beginning of the end of
Ms heard's abuse hoax against Johnny
Depp
is this true or false
false
and why is it false
because
unfortunately all of this is real
and what I mentioned earlier about how
Preposterous it would have to be
for this to be the celebrate hoax I
couldn't believe it I couldn't fathom
one day that that would actually be
legitimately the position that he
through a lawyer would take
albeit online where he could get away
with it for some objection calls for
speculation
why why is this so absurd
because
Johnny and I lift this we lived through
this I lived through this and I narrowly
survived it but I survived it
and you know I have
mountains of evidence mountains of proof
and yet it it was it won't be good
enough for people who are seeking to
make money off of Johnny's success
abstraction your honor culture
speculation that's fine okay
so I'm going to take you now to the
damages that you've suffered as a result
of these statements by Mr Waldman on Mr
Depp's behalf
please tell the jury how you were doing
reputation that's that's a legal
conclusion in your honor
I'm sorry we moved to strike council's
testimony
uh from the record we'll disregard that
question all right your next question
what was your understanding of on whose
behalf Mr Waldman was making those three
statements objection Locker Foundation
cancer speculation and you want to
approach again that's not what we just
said here
so we'll move forward to my other
question here how were you please tell
the jury how were you doing
reputationally before these three
statements were made beginning April
2020 April 8 was the first of them
objection your honor I'm going to object
on lack of foundation
she can talk about her reputation
overruled I love
I took hard work
it you know
it took a lot of hard work
um on my part but I was able to work get
my life back on track
um I was taking care of my you know
myself emotionally and my career was
working really hard I was able to star
in a major success I worked on a TV
series that I had been touched to for a
very long time I became an ambassador
for several non-profits that I deeply
care about I was doing a lot of really
you know it felt really good to be doing
the social work and the charity work
that I was doing and I was also filming
and working and planning on um I was
awaiting a schedule from
uh Warner Brothers for Aquaman 2 the
sequel
um and I had wrapped on that TV series I
mentioned and I was waiting to start
doing publicity for it to promote it and
I had a uh a a campaign a global
campaign as a spokesperson for a major
Beauty brand
so things were you know the trajectory
was was positive
so how how did things change after these
statements were made
I remember around the time
um
unfortunately I lost my mother uh around
I mean on the first of April
and I remember it was uh when I was
grieving her that I uh got a a call
that I should be expecting a script uh
for my role in Aquaman construction
honor hearsay
approve the truth
um so I was waiting I was waiting a
schedule uh and a script for that
feeling concerned that you know I
wouldn't have enough time to to grieve
before having to get back into work I
had a press schedule to promote the TV
series I was doing and uh I was shooting
things for this uh
Beauty brand and then uh I I remember
at that time
um the beauty brand
had to suspend posting what I had what
what I just shot for them because uh
they were getting bombarded uh objection
your honor this is hearsay
sustain the objection okay all right so
they they said no I mean they suspended
what I had shot objection your honor
sustain the objection okay you were you
were you actively involved in campaigns
for L'Oreal before these articles I was
were you actively involved in campaigns
with L'Oreal after these articles no
were you with the stand you were talking
about the TV series that was the stand
correct yes the TV series that I had
already completed all right were you
actively involved in publicity for the
stand prior to these articles
yes I was were you actively involved in
the publicity after these articles no
the shoots were canceled things were
canceled with respect to Aquaman one
Aquaman 2 Aquaman two you'd already
started Aquaman one right just so we're
and they called it Aquaman at that time
but now there's an Aquaman too just
right for that's correct okay so were
you actively scheduling uh timing for
filming and scripts for Aquaman 2 before
these articles yes I was were you
actively scheduling after these articles
no the the communication stopped
um
at that point all right I'm going to
Michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 1258
I'm going to show you what has been
marked as defendants exhibit 1258 it
stated September 21
2015. do you recognize this document yes
okay what is it it is uh the Justice
League
Aquaman contract okay you're entering to
move the admission of defendants exhibit
1258 any objection
yes your honor may we approach sure
so
Amber can you explain to me how that the
contract structure was for justice
league and options just explain to the
jury please
it's um structured like a three picture
option you I signed on to do Justice
League where my character was introduced
the fee is
you know small relative to what it will
become if and when you do the other
options or movies
in that I'm under that umbrella so it
was the contract for Justice League
which could then become Justice League
two or it could be Aquaman or it could
be some other movie within the DC
universe
and the second picture ended up being
Aquaman
uh and then the third picture Aquaman 2
each time it the fee goes up but
objection honor this is calls for
speculation lack of foundation it
overruled out loud
as far as the contract is concerned
that's what the contract says all right
and if we go to page six
so what was your fee going to be for
Aquaman and what was it for Aquaman
uh one million okay then was there also
box office bonuses opportunities
yes I believe okay yes there are box
office bonuses and if it makes a certain
amount in the box office you um you get
a uh a bonus
okay and it says picture number two at
the time you entered into the contract
and and uh with the unjustice league did
they know what what the picture would be
no as I mentioned before when you do the
contract caption calls for speculation
all right I'll sustain that objection
okay
so ultimately what was picture number
two Aquaman all right and then uh what
was it for picture number three
Aquaman 2. okay and what was the fee
under the option agreement at that time
2 million
okay
um now did you have contracts with
L'Oreal
yes I did okay and can you just describe
for the jury what was involved with
L'Oreal you talked about being involved
in campaigns and then not just just
explain that to them if you can as a
spokesperson I'm just involved with the
brand as a representative and a certain
amount of commitment you have to do
throughout the year on social media and
on red carpets promoting various
products or
um
you know causes their advancing
generally it's just like a brand
ambassadorship
and did you
um well let's go let's pull up 1262.
and this is dated as of April 25 2018
correct that's correct was that your
first contract with L'Oreal
I believe so yes okay
and did was that for a term
a specific term
yes it was okay was it for two years
yes it says two-year contract and that
sounds right all right and then I'm
going to ask you to turn to 1264.
and that's April 20 20 20.
and what if anything did L'Oreal do with
regard to extending your contract then
they
extended it they chose to extend it with
the option to kind of
all right and did they extend it just an
additional three months uh that would
look at paragraph one
yes they did okay and what if any work
did you do for L'Oreal after these three
statements were made
uh
I have only been able to participate in
I believe one live event
that they also couldn't promote or use
the material from because of objection
your honor calls for speculation okay
now let's go to 1265
and this is
as of November 15 2021 this is another
extension with L'Oreal correct
yes it is and if you look at the second
option term under paragraph one it's an
extension of 20 months is that correct
that is correct okay and what if any
work have you been able to do for
L'Oreal since this ex since this
contract
as I stated I believe I've only done
one in-person event with them and they
couldn't use the material okay
now I I let's talk about the stand for a
minute let's pull up 1263.
and this is dated July 3 2019.
and I believe you indicated that you had
already filmed it by the time these
statements were made in April and June
of 2020 is that correct that's correct
okay and what if any marketing
opportunities were you participating in
prior to those articles
uh we had
appearances talk show
um press the normal kind of group cast
press junket promotional material photo
shoot
um and I was uh I had
um various publicity engagements lined
up like magazine a magazine cover
um
that that sort of thing to promote the
film I mean to promote the series
and what if anything were you able to do
with marketing opportunities after the
three articles were published
uh none
none what if any uh covers were you on
after that for the stand they pulled the
offer for that so none okay and while
we're on this uh agreement if you look
at the second page how much were you
paid
for the stand
it's at 6c
200 200 000 an episode okay
now let's pull up defendants exhibit
1266.
have you been able to get any work since
that time
I have done one
small independent film okay and tell the
jury what that is
I shot a film in Guatemala
it's a small independent meaning it
doesn't have distribution or you know
yeah it doesn't distribution or anything
it's a lower budget film that I had been
attached to for many years called into
the fire
and 1266 has as of January 13 2022 do
you see that yes okay when did you
actually film for this in Guatemala
uh
March
I believe it was March of this year
and do you recall what your compensation
was for that
I don't off the top of my head if you
can look at alh17628
it's paragraph 6A
oh uh
65 000. okay
and have you participated in Aquaman 2.
I have
and tell us about that
uh I had to fight to I fought really
hard to stay in the movie they
um didn't want to
include me in the film objection your
honor hearsay I'll sustain the
attraction
um
did you ultimately were you ultimately
able to get to film in Aquaman 2.
a
very part down version of that role yes
okay what if any if anything changed in
the script
they took away uh a lot of objection
you're on Earth hearsay I think she can
lock a foundation overruled as the
script
go ahead I was given a script and then
given new versions of the script
that had taken away scenes that the
that that had action in it that had that
depicted
um my character
and uh and another character without
giving any spoilers away you know
they're two characters fighting with one
another and
they they basically took a bunch out of
my role they didn't
yeah they just removed a bunch oh and
what if any leverage did you have to
negotiate a higher salary beyond the two
million objection speculation
I'll sustain the objection what if any
effort did you make to
negotiate a higher salary for your
participation
I couldn't renegotiate my contract and
why not
actually in this call s for hearsay
and speculation do you know
you know still the same abduction as
your honor sustain the objection
um
yeah
all right
Amber I'm going to ask you to describe
to this jury
the emotional
impact on you
of these three statements that we have
talked about these three counter claim
statements please describe how this has
impacted you
um
these statements are used over and over
and over and over again
online
to reverberate re-eco and re-energize
objection honor this is not responsive
lack of foundation and hearsay she gets
to give her classes in for it well her
emotional the question was were your
emotional impact of these statements
okay
impact it has on me is every time I look
at it uh which is every day
I am set back I have to relive it I have
to to have my the worst
most painful things I've ever gone
through
painful memories I've ever had the
things I've narrowly survived at times
embarrassing intimate details that I
never wanted
to be known never wanted to be public
ever and to have them use every single
day to call me a liar I have to relive
this every single day that I have to
address those claims
over and over again the most intimate
embarrassing
deeply humiliating and personal things
that I've survived
our use against me every day
over and over again
into torture and so I'm in so much pain
emotionally
I'm I'm I just
wanted him to leave me alone I wanted to
move on with my life
and he won't let me
by making statements like this he won't
let me
I have to be here today I have to be
reliving it every single time
he with these statements with these
these these leaks these comments
once again
makes me
have to speak to the most horrifying
things I've lived through
it's torture
it's torturous I want you have to do
that
I want to move on with my life
I have a baby I want to move on I want
to move on I want Tony to move on to
mom leave me alone
thank you I have no further questions
all right ladies and gentlemen it's
probably a good time to go ahead and
take our afternoon recess based on that
so go ahead and uh do not discuss the
case and uh don't do any outside
research okay we'll see in 15 minutes
okay thank you
Police Court is still in session I need
it to be quiet in the gallery thank you
actually
all right well we just make it 325 then
we'll come back at 3 25. thanks all
right thank you
all right
all right
sure okay
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
all right be seated cross-examination
good afternoon Miss heard good afternoon
Mr Depp hasn't looked at you once this
entire trial has he
not that I've noticed no
you've looked at him though many times
haven't you
yes I have
you know exactly why Mr dab won't look
back at you don't you
I do
he promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
I don't recall if he said that
one of the last times you ever saw Mr
Depp was when you met him in San
Francisco in July of 2016 right
that was the second to last time I saw
him yes and this was after you had
publicly accused him of domestic
violence
I got my restraining order before that
yes and this is after you had obtained
the domestic violence restraining order
against him that's correct
let's place play plaintiff's exhibit one
two two nine
um
for the record it's at 11 0 1 through
1209
I'm gonna ask that it be admitted into
evidence in the objection to one two two
nine
yes
yes all right one two two nine you want
to enter in its entirety yes please okay
one two two nine entered in its entirety
go ahead and play your picture
[Music]
no oh no a hug will save it all all this
everything
please stop me
please stop
[Music]
I just wanted
to buy it
no because I'm nothing you and I will
always be nothing to you
but
yeah
loves each other
don't take my [ __ ] glasses
you know like [ __ ] looking it's not
my [ __ ] eyes you will not see my eyes
again
that's you and Mr death and not
recording that is and this is from when
you and Mr dad met in San Francisco in
July of 2016 right
yes that's what it sounds like that was
in the hotel we met once after that as
well
this is after you publicly accused him
of domestic abuse
yes and got my tro
and he tells you you will not see my
eyes again doesn't he
uh yes he does in that recording and he
kept that promise hasn't he
as far as I know he cannot look at me
he won't look at you right Mr
he
can't
one of the first questions your Council
asked you on Direct is why are you here
do you remember that I do
let's please play plain to exhibit
357a which is already an Evidence your
honor and for the record it's 21 22
through 2140.
think tell the world Johnny tell them
Johnny Depp I find
that man I'm a victim
and I you know it's a fair fight it
seems how many people believe or besides
of you
that's her voice on that recording right
yes it is you were speaking with Mr Depp
yes
and you said to Mr debb you can tell you
can please tell people that it was a
fair fight and see what the jury and the
judge think tell the world Johnny tell
them Johnny Depp I Johnny Depp a man a
victim too of domestic violence end
quote that's what you said right
I was saying it to the man who beat me
up yes I thought it was preposterous
and the man you beat up numerous times
right was heard I could never hurt
Johnny
you're here in this courtroom because Mr
Dot finally told the world that he's the
victim of domestic violence
I know that he is suing me
um and has sued
other people or corporations that have
said that as well
you didn't think he would tell the world
he was a victim of domestic violence did
you
I
found it hard to believe that he could
or that he
would do that considering the
relationship he and I had I I thought it
would be
crazy for him to do so knowing what
I know we lived through
or as you said to him in that recording
he was going to believe that Johnny Depp
a man is a victim of domestic violence
right
with all due respect I wasn't saying it
because he's a man I was saying it
because he was a man who beat me up for
five years
Mr Depp is your victim isn't he
and once he left you you continue to
abuse him publicly by calling him an
abuser didn't you
he is an abuser and you can look either
of us up online and figure out who's
being abused online
let's look at some of that
Mr Depp wears rings on every finger
doesn't he misheard
that's my experience yes and they're not
delicate rings are they
no they are not
every one of its fingers is adorned your
words big chunky Rings isn't that right
that's my experience of him
and Mr Depp is always wearing Rings
right Miss heard
that's my experience of him
and you've never known him not to wear
these rings
and that's my experiences he normally
wore Rings yes so Mr Depp was wearing
these big chunky rings on every finger
every incident of abuse you've described
to this jury right
I can't say for certain it was in every
single incident but you've never known
him not to wear Rings right in general
um my experience with Johnny is that he
will he wears Rings almost all the time
miss her do you recall giving testimony
in a deposition in this matter in
January of this year I do
can we please play
from your deposition day two
512 page 512 lines 11 through 15.
you said he hit you and he where he was
he was wearing Rings right miss her so
he hit you with
rings on every finger I don't know if
I've ever known Johnny to not wear rings
Miss heard you testify to an incident in
March of 2013 where Mr Depp hit you in
the face multiple times do you recall
that that's correct and you testified
quote
you don't know how many times he hit you
in the face
that's correct
so Mr Depp hit you in the face multiple
times while he was wearing rings on this
occasion correct
which occasion in March tree referencing
you weren't the testimony that you gave
on day 15 of this trial
March of 2013. you weren't specific us
to the day
there were several incidents
the one where he hit you several times
in the face
uh there were there was so I'm sorry
just so I understand better there were
several incidents in March which one are
you asking me about the time that he hit
you several times in the face wearing
rings
well
he pretty much 2013.
right
what are you asking me I'm sorry
he was wearing rings on that occasion I
pretty much always knew him to wear
Rings okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 170 a which is
already an evidence for Honor
you testified that this is the picture
you took after that incident right Miss
heard
yes that was one where he grabbed me
and hit you in the face so many times
that you don't remember isn't that
correct that's correct
and there's no injuries to your face in
this picture are there
not that this picture shows
and there's no medical records
reflecting that you sought treatment
after this alleged incident either
I did not seek medical treatment at this
time
so there's no medical records reflecting
any injuries to your face after hitch he
hit you several times I did not need to
go to the doctor at the time
despite hitting you several times that
you lost count with rings on your on his
fingers that's correct I did not seek
medical attention
other than my therapist
he testified to another incident in
March of 2013 13 where Mr Depp hit you
while he was wearing a lot of rings
do you remember that testimony
yes ma'am and you testified you felt
like your lip went through your teeth
and it got a little Blood on the wall
yes okay I remember that
there isn't a picture of you with
injuries after that alleged incident is
there
I don't know if I've seen one
um I I can't recall there are a lot of
pictures
you didn't produce any photographs after
that alleged incident did you I don't
know if I took one or if it's included
I'm not I'm not quite sure which ones
you didn't show any pictures to the
story after describing that alleged
incident that you're
teeth
your lip went into your teeth you don't
remember that right I didn't show any
pictures to this jury after describing
that incident right
I don't believe I've seen that picture
admitted
that picture doesn't exist
I don't know which one you're talking
about there were we have pictures from
March 2013 yes
the only picture that you've produced
and shown to the story is the one that
was just put up on the screen
where you said he hit you multiple times
in the face and you appear to have what
is a bruise on your arm correct I
believe this is the only picture that's
in evidence right now
that's the only picture you've shown to
the story from March 2013. correct I
believe so
you testified about an incident in
Russia on or about June 26 2013. do you
remember that
yes that's correct you testify that Mr
Deb quote walk to you in the face
that's correct
and you went to the bathroom after that
right I did
and then according to your testimony
when you came out of the bathroom Jerry
judge Mr Depp's security guard has
passed away pointed out that your nose
was bleeding right
he did that in the hallway
and you said you hadn't known that your
nose was bleeding until Jerry judge
pointed it out to you
yes that's correct I was unaware until
he brought it up to me I didn't see it
when I was in the bathroom but I wasn't
looking
so so it's your testimony that you went
into the bathroom and didn't look in the
mirror which I assume was in the
bathroom to notice that your nose was
bleeding that's not why I went into the
bathroom I went into the bathroom
um crying I I don't even know if I paid
attention to the mirror I certainly
didn't enough to notice any blood
you didn't take any pictures of your
bloody nose either did you I did not
but pictures were taken of you in Russia
though isn't that correct yes that's
correct way to press or a dinner
um let's please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit one two four eight
it's heard this is a picture of you and
Mr Depp in Russia correct that's correct
I'm gonna move to admit
all right no objection one two four
eight in evidence you can publish
and this is you and Mr Depp in Russia
for The Lone Ranger Premiere correct it
was a dinner function I believe for in
promotion of the movie wasn't the
premiere if I recall
you don't have any visible injuries to
your face do you
none that you can see
um let's look at plaintiff's exhibit
1249
this is a picture of you isn't it right
that's correct
I'm gonna move to a zip
admit exhibit one two four nine all
right one two four nine in evidence
this is also a picture from when you
were in Russia for The Lone Ranger
Premiere right that is correct you have
no visible injuries to your face do you
none that you can see
even though Mr Depp whacked him in the
face so hard that your nose bled
uh he did
while wearing chunky big Rings right
that's correct
you also testify that Mr Dept again
walked you in the face after the Met
Gala in May of 2014 right that is
correct
you testified that you thought he hit
you so hard he broke your nose
that's correct
you said your nose was quote swollen
discolored red
that is correct I took a picture of that
you testified you took a picture of your
face after this I did but you didn't
show that picture to the story did you I
would like to
but you didn't show it did you that's
not up to me
you understand you were under an
obligation to produce all photographs
after any alleged incidents of violence
right misheard I produced everything
didn't produce any photographs after the
Met Gala I produced everything
you also understand that you're under an
obligation to produce all medical
records reflecting any injuries you
allegedly sustained from Mr Depp correct
that's correct and you haven't produced
any pictures or any medical records
reflecting a broken nose after the Met
gal in May of 2014 have you
I have given everything to my lawyers
everything I've turned over literally
everything that I have is that your
testimony misheard that you sought
medical treatment after Mr Depp
allegedly broke your nose after the Met
Gala not after the Met Gala I did not
seek medical attention no
he also attended an event after the Met
Gala in May of 2014 didn't you that is
correct you went to the All-Star Comedy
tribute to Don Rickles that is correct
that was the next night after the Met
Gala that is correct and there were
pictures of you taken at this event yes
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
one two five two
this is a picture of you misheard
yes it is at that event yes it is the
night after the Met Gala yes it is the
night after Mr Depp allegedly broke your
nose
uh I'm not sure if it was broken for the
record but yeah you should see what it
looked like underneath the makeup
he whacked you so hard in the face you
thought you had broken your nose exactly
right
um permission to admit this photograph
all right one two five two in evidence
this is a picture of you Mr dapp and Don
Rickles right that is correct
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
one two five three
this is another picture from that
evening right Miss heard yes it is
permission to admit exhibit one two five
three and publish it
all right so mood one two five three in
evidence
this is a picture of you and Mr Depp
at the event the night after Mr Depp
allegedly walked him in the face so hard
you thought he had broken your nose
he did whack me in the face and I did
think it broke my nose and this is you
the night after yes it is
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
one two five four
this is also a picture of you at the
same event correct Miss heard that is
correct
move to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
two five four
all right one two five four in evidence
you can publish okay and just to confirm
now that the jury can see it this is a
picture of you at the same event the
night after Mr Depp allegedly walked you
in the face so hard and you thought he
broke your nose
this is a picture of me
um after he did whack me in the face the
night after right
yes it is I believe it was the night
after yes
your nose doesn't appear to be injured
in any of these pictures does it
misheard
I'm wearing makeup
your nose doesn't appear to be injured
in any of these pictures does it
misheard
that's why I'm wearing makeup right and
makeup covers up swelling right
makeup will not cover up swelling eyes
well though
ice will cover up swelling
ice reduces swelling normally the
swelling after that kind of injury is
not as bad as you might imagine and for
me
it wasn't that bad I have a picture of
it underneath the makeup that's how I
know how to reference it
a picture you haven't produced to this
jury right Miss heard I absolutely I
produce everything but you haven't shown
it to this jury I would very much like
to
it's not my job
may we approach yes that's fine
thank you
Miss heard you testified that in January
of 2015 there was an incident in Tokyo
before Mr Depp's Mordecai the film
Mordecai's Premiere is that correct
that's correct you told this jury that
on this occasion Mr Depp was kneeling on
your back
that's correct in the closet you also
told this jury that you wore backless
dress to the Mordecai Premiere that very
same night
I did and you testified that you were
checking for bruises in the car on the
way back on the way to the event to make
sure that there were quote no visible
marks right I was checking on my phone
um after the event to see to make sure
that nothing
they couldn't see anything
your testimony was that you were
checking in the car on the way to the
event
to make sure that there were no marks on
your back
perhaps I misspoke or misunderstood it
was on the way back from it was after I
was concerned after you know concerned
that there would be marks in any
photographs since we were being
photographed at Johnny's press event you
didn't show this jury a picture of you
in that backless dress though did you
I don't know what you mean I'm sorry you
didn't show this jury a picture of you
at the Mordecai premiere wearing a
backless dress did you
I haven't had the opportunity to okay I
assume you have it I do let's please
pull up plaintiff's exhibit one two five
six
this is a picture of you and Mr dapp or
the back of you
at the Mordecai Premiere in Tokyo
correct Miss heard that is correct
your honor I'd move to admit and publish
this picture cart1256 in evidence
this is you in the backless dress at the
Mordecai Premiere in Tokyo right
that is correct you would agree that
there are no bruises or visible marks on
your back in this picture
no not that I could see
I'll show you one other photo if we
could please have plaintiff's exhibit
one two five seven
[Music]
this is a front angle picture of you and
Mr dapp at that Premiere correct that is
correct
move to admit planches exhibit
one two five seven all right one two
five seven it is
I'll show you one more picture
plaintiff's exhibit one two five eight
and again miss heard this is you and Mr
dad but the Mordecai premiere yes it is
move to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
two five eight all right one two five
eight in evidence publish
and that's the backless dress right Miss
heard that is correct
you also told this jury about an
incident in Australia in March of 2015.
yes that's correct
you testify that after this alleged
incident you had cuts on your forearms
right
yes that's true you testified that you
had cuts on the bottoms of your feet as
well
yes that's true
and you testified that you had a bruise
across your jaw from when Mr Depp quote
clocked you in the face end quote that's
true
you didn't take any pictures of these
injuries while you were in Australia did
you
I don't think no I don't think I took
any pictures
you just took two pictures of Mr death's
writing on a mirror isn't that right I
believe so yes
so you had your phone on you right
at some point I did have my phone and
your iPad I had my iPad I believe you
testified that you were also raped with
a liquor bottle in Australia right Miss
heard
yes
you testified you bled from your vagina
as a result of that sexual assault
yes
there aren't any medical records
reflecting that you sought medical
treatment for any of these injuries are
there
I did not seek medical treatment after
Australia no not for the rape
no I did not want to tell anyone not for
the cuts
no not for the injuries to your face I
didn't need to
you also told the jury about an incident
on December 15
2015 right
uh where I'm sorry
December 15 2015. yes that's correct you
told this jury that after this incident
you had a broken nose
it certainly felt like it
it's her do you recall giving testimony
on day 16th
in this trial
right yes
if you have
transcript for the jury or excuse me
okay all right we'll get it
I will do thank you Judy
may I approach the witness your honor
all right yes ma'am and would you like a
coffee yes please
I can please direct your attention Miss
heard to Paige
of day 16 4593
the jury trials transcript
foreign
lines
8 through 13.
on which page I'm sorry four five nine
three
yes
starting on line eight I thought I
probably had a concussion and certainly
thought excuse me let's write that let's
start over I thought I had
I thought I probably had a concussion
and certainly that I had a broken nose
there was a blood everywhere blood all
over the pillows my head was bleeding
from the ripped out hair chunks of hair
on the floor all over the place actually
so lines
nine that I had a broken nose
do you recall giving that testimony Miss
heard yes exactly
so you had a broken nose right that's
absolutely what I thought
I had two black eyes after this incident
right
I did have two black eyes after that
incident
you testified that you also had a busted
lip from when Mr Depp punched you
that is uh correct
from December yes that's correct you
testified that the lip wound kept
reopening when you moved your mouth
that's correct
he also testified that you had bruising
on your temple
that's correct and bruising on your chin
correct
you also testified that your head was
bleeding from where Mr Depp ripped
chunks of your hair out
remember yes
and that you had quote gross [ __ ]
and quote bruising around your temple
uh in my scalp yeah
now for this incident you did take
pictures
that's correct
and we will look at some of those in a
minute but I first want to talk to you
about your appearance on the James
Corden show
can I close this sure
you appeared on the James Corden show
the day after this alleged incident
right I did
and that was December 16 2015.
yes that's correct
let's please pull up a clip of your
appearance from that evening if we could
plaintiff's exhibit 35 and for the
record we will only be playing a portion
of this so we will call it plaintiff's
exhibit 35a or any objection
35a in evidence
I grew up you know in Texas riding
horses and oh really you know it's not a
big ballet Community out there in Texas
not so much shooting guns yes but ballet
no
so I wanted to train for it and there
were some ballet sequences that
um we wanted to have the option to to
incorporate into the movie so I trained
forever and I have two left feet I'm the
most klutzy person in the world and I
have no um
Grace
your honor I'm so sorry but it's not
published to the jury if we may have it
please publish okay thank you apologies
if we can please start that over start
it over I'm sorry thank your honor
I grew up you know in Texas riding
horses and oh really you know it's not a
big ballet Community out there in Texas
no no not so much shooting guns yes but
ballet no so I wanted to train for it
and there were some ballet sequences uh
that um we wanted to have the option to
to incorporate into the movie so I
trained forever and I have two left feet
I'm the most klutzy person in the world
and I have no um
Grace
I knew I had to train for it and what
they don't tell you I mean I in I
crammed about three months of solid
training in and I'm kind of like working
my way up from the floor and learning
the technical aspect of ballet and I've
got these dances down technically
perfectly I'm learning all the movements
but the last thing we get to are the
hands
and I haven't yet got to that point but
everything else is working and I'm
acting it up on my face and I'm selling
the ballet and I think I'm doing really
good at this point kind of nailing it
and so I send videos and and images to
my friends to like get encouragement
look for their support
and everyone shoots back what's with the
claw hand and I look and I realize like
all the stress and fear of Performing
and doing this thing and just kind of
like funneled out through the one thing
that I hadn't yet
doing so I'd be doing some amazing you
know I'd be doing like a jump with a
back bend and you can see this like
graceful falling and my hands are like
hahaha
and my face though it's like I thought
that you saw on the cliff like this
beautiful 1920s you know stage makeup on
and like flower crowns and all this
stuff and then my hand and my face and
then my hands
that was you on the James Corden show on
December 16 2015 right Miss heard that
was
let's please pull up plant's exhibit 98
these are pictures of you on the James
Corden show on December 16 2015 right
Miss heard
they look like freeze frames
um like screen grabs
Stills they're not like a it's not like
a photo shoot it doesn't seem
but on the James Corden show correct
from that appearance yes move to admit
and publish plaintiff's exhibit 98. all
right in the spirit you could move the
microphone and turn it on for you so
Judy and I are having trouble hearing
you sorry about that all right thank you
all right 98 in evidence thank you
that's a photo of you opening your mouth
on the right right that's correct
and again a larger view the same photo
on the bottom
that's correct with a split lip
you've seen pictures of it without
makeup
yeah so you've had a split lip when you
I should have in your mouth that way I
sure did in those photographs absolutely
you did take pictures of your alleged
injuries after December 15th correct and
you showed those to this jury
I sure did yes okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 516 which is already
in evidence
[Music]
you testified that this is a picture of
you after the incident on December 15
2015 right it was
and if we could also please pull up
defendants exhibit 517 which is also an
Evidence
that's fine thank you your honor this is
also a picture of you after the incident
on December 15 2015.
that's correct
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 409 which is already in evidence
foreign
these pictures ended up in People
magazine in June of 2016. isn't that
right Miss heard that's correct
you gave these pictures to People
magazine after you publicly accused Mr
death of domestic abuse didn't you I
didn't personally know
this is you protecting Mr Depp after you
got the restraining order against him
isn't it no this is him calling me a
liar and me forcing to prove it
as I mentioned to you earlier so you did
give these pictures to People magazine
No I gave these um pictures actually to
my lawyers and my Representatives at the
time so it's your testimony misheard
that your lawyers and representatives
gave these pictures of their client to
People magazine in the middle of a
contentious divorce I certainly did not
personally give it no
you also have a medical record from
after the December 15 2015 incident
don't you
a partial one yes you went to see Dr
Kipper's office a couple days later
that's right he wasn't in the office
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 47 which is already in evidence
this is your medical record for December
17 2015. isn't it Miss heard
that's correct
and this record doesn't document any
physical injuries on you does it
I I don't think so no I I don't think I
spoke
to Kipper I didn't speak to Kipper
um that day
and you guys to Dr Kipper's office and
we're seeing correct I went to Dr Kipper
uh went to Dr Kipper's office for a
concussion check right okay and this
medical record is from that visit
correct
partially yes
scroll down please if we could
the signature Kipper down below this is
the entirety of the medical record right
Miss heard yes what I meant by partial
is I didn't talk about what happened to
me I didn't get into my injuries I
didn't get into what happened or ask for
anything other than should I get some
sort of scan done
but this record doesn't document any
physical injuries on you does it
uh I'd have to read it in full but I I
don't know well let's do that
we could please go
well under skin on the second page
it reads intact normal color moisture
hair distribution texture trigger
no signs of
oh this is gonna be hard cyanosis
motling jaundice
It also says I'm a well-nourished male
right
I have no idea what that means I I think
this medical record's missing a lot of
things
yeah but it doesn't document any
physical injuries it doesn't seem to be
documenting anything
probably because there was nothing to
document right Miss heard I disagree
with you on that
you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you broke your nose
during your relationship with Mr Depp do
you
uh I saw an ENT after my relationship
ended
and you saw an e and it's your testimony
under oath that you saw an ENT for
broken noses that you sustain as a
result of Mr duck no but the ENT told me
I succeed objection fractures
sustain the objection I'll move to
strike thank you
so again just to
try my question there's no medical
records reflecting that you broke your
nose during your relationship with Mr
Depp is there a misheard I don't know
what made it an Evidence but I do know
that I documented that visit and that
everything was given to my attorneys
misheard you never went to see any
doctor or surgeon
to treat a broken nose during your
relationship with Mr Depp yes or no I
never sought treatment for broken nose
while I was with Johnny
or after you were with Mr Depp as a
result of any injuries you sustained as
a result of Mr Depp afterwards yes I did
and you didn't produce those medical
records in this case I'm an eject your
honor she did
I did I I don't know all right they have
not been produced
could come and approach
you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you required any dental
work during your relationship with Mr
Depp do you
uh I don't know
I don't work I don't recall
you don't recall one way or another
seeking dental care for any injuries you
allegedly sustained uh you asked me
about if I had produced records or if I
had records that's a different question
did you ever see a dentist or an oral
surgeon
as a result of any injuries he sustained
with Mr Depp
not
about any injury I had from Johnny no
and you don't have any
meds reflecting that you required any
reconstructive work during your
relationship with Mr Duff do you
I never required reconstructive work
so there would be no records
what you do have misheard are pictures
of Mr
right
the jury saw a lot of those
yes
sir let's take a look at defendant's
exhibit 1090 which is already in
evidence
you took this Photograph right Miss
heard that's correct
and you testified that this was taken in
Tokyo in July of 2013 correct
yes
so you decided to take a picture of Mr
death asleep on the floor
he was passed out
and I took a picture of him because he
uh wouldn't remember he claimed he
didn't pass out that way and sometimes
security would carry him like a baby
into bed and get him changed
and he would be none the wiser so I
started taking pictures of it so that he
knew
that it was real that it had gotten this
bad
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
1091 which is already in evidence
you took this picture as well
yes
and this is the picture that was taken
in the Bahamas right
it's one of them yes
and this is a picture of Mr Depp taking
a nap on his tropical island
I believe he was on the nod but as he
would say
sleeping on the nod on his Island
they're very different in my opinion and
yes he is on the island
on vacation
uh we were on vacation yes
let's also take a look at defendants
exhibit 1092 which is also an Evidence
we also took this picture right Miss
heard that's correct I did and this is
another picture of Mr Depp asleep in a
chair
no he was nodding off uh sleep is
different when you're nodding off you're
high on drugs didn't even feel the
cigarette in his hand that had you know
been burning on his leg uh it was caused
for alarm for me naturally
um because I cared about him
that's mounting under oath that Mr Depp
is holding a cigarette in this picture
he had been
seemed to really like taking pictures of
Mr dot while he's sleeping don't you
I hated it
I hated it
let's look at defendants exhibit 1094
which is also an Evidence
he took this picture of Mr death as well
didn't you I did you decided to take a
picture of Mr Deb asleep with ice cream
spilled all over him right
he was nodding off and I was worried
about how bad the medications and the
medication change and the drug use had
gotten where he wouldn't even feel ice
cream or a lit cigarette on him and it
scared me a picture of it yes I um I
wanted him to get help and Johnny's
surrounded by enablers who clean up
after him daughter I'm gonna move to
strike everything after yes that she
took this picture it's still responsive
here on it the question was did you take
this picture
all right I'll sustain the objection
thank you your honor
this isn't a very flattering picture of
Mr Depp is it no it's not
you wouldn't agree that this is or you
would agree with me that this is an
embarrassing scene right
yes I think it's a part of getting help
is looking at it and seeing it but you
sent this picture to one of your friends
didn't you
uh I don't recall
um if we could please pull up defendants
exhibit 252
we'll only be looking at the portion of
this document so if we could please call
it defendants exhibit 252a
and for ease we've gone ahead and
redacted it
yes I was asking for support that's
correct
it's no question yet miss heard so
directing your attention I'm going to
move to admit
exhibit
252a any objection
any objection Mr
could you turn turn on could you turn
your microphone again I'm sorry
thank you
um I need to see it first because I
don't know what they redacted two five
two we redacted the identifiers
and anything that's not misheard text
messages
consistent with hearsay
you heard me we approach okay
foreign
Mr does just refresh your recollection
that you did in fact send this picture
to your friend Rocky Pennington yes I
did
[Music]
he sent it to her
on August 7 2014 at 11 24 PM correct
that is correct
so you sent Miss Pennington this picture
of Mr Depp with ice cream spilled on him
right that is correct and you wrote
quote this is what I've been dealing
with end quote did I read that right you
did read that right that's correct and
this is you protecting Mr Depp
that is me getting support from my best
friend this is you supporting Mr Depp
this is me getting support from my best
friend I also need support
you weren't afraid the the monster would
get upset that you took this picture
This was um opiate Johnny
this is a different
version of him this is opiate on the nod
Johnny and you weren't afraid that Opia
Johnny or the monster as you called him
would get upset that you sent this
picture to your friend well he's all of
those things of course he could get
upset and of course that's scary to me
of course but stop you from sending this
picture to your friend did it why would
it
startups hand right hand is in his
pocket right
right yeah sure it's correct
he also showed this jury pictures of
cocaine do you recall that
yes that's correct
please take a look at one of those
if we could please pull up defendant's
exhibit
167a which is already in evidence
directing your attention is referred to
photograph this is the photograph you
took in March of 2013 right that is
correct and this was taken at your
apartment in Orange yes
and this is your breakfast table that is
correct
and it's your testimony that Mr Depp
left this breakfast table just the way
you took it
that is correct
so this is what the table looked like
after Mr debb had been doing cocaine
uh well clearly he has yet to snort
these lines
there are four lines of cocaine on this
table right Miss heard in this picture I
see four lines
there isn't any cocaine residue around
those lines right
uh I not that I can tell him no
doesn't really look like anyone's been
doing cocaine off that table does it
it's all due respect I'm not sure you
know how that works
I'm asking if you do you've testified
you've done cocaine I have doesn't
really look like Mr Depp or anyone was
doing cocaine off that table does it uh
I beg to differ with you on that when
you snort cocaine typically it goes into
your nose
and then it doesn't stay on your table
there's residue from that cocaine when
your lips and nose touch the table right
will the tampon applicator next to
um
the
credit card I mean um driver's license
that you see is
a device that I believe my sister had
taught him
to use in order to
put the cocaine
uh in your nose
Mr death is a pretty heavy smoker right
he is
and and that's a cigarette in the
ashtray in the back there
um back right yes it looks like one of
his hand rolls
just no other cigarettes in that ashtray
either
I see one cigarette
the one that's not smoked
that's correct
there's no Ash in that ashtray either is
there
uh not that I can tell in this picture
it's pretty clean
in this picture it looks like it yes
it's a pretty neat table wouldn't you
agree
um
depends on what you would call neat I
suppose and you sent this picture to
your friend Rocky Pennington as well
didn't you I sure did
and when you sent it you said quote look
at my morning or something like that is
that right yay for mornings
so you have a habit of sending stage
photographs to your friend Rocky don't
you I had a habit of communicating with
my best friend about what was going on
in my life
have any pictures of
it's actually consuming
I mean I don't think I have a picture of
him mid snort no
you don't even have any pictures of Mr
Depp with cocaine what do you mean by
that
holding cocaine standing next to cocaine
um
sitting next to cocaine
I don't know I don't know
well you haven't shown any of those
pictures like that to the jury have you
I don't know I no I haven't
and you were never able to catch Mr Depp
with cocaine on film either
were you I never tried
but you were able to catch him sleeping
right
I have seen him pass out in all sorts of
places yes
and you also captured a video of Mr Depp
in the kitchen that was played again for
this jury today beating up some cabinets
do you recall that
sorry say that again you recall
capturing Mr Depp in the kitchen of one
of his homes
beating up some cabinets
yes
slamming things around yes so you took
that video of Mr death in the kitchen
right I did I did and you took it on one
of your iPad devices I took it on my
iPad
you were deposed in August of 2016 in
connection with your divorce proceedings
from Mr Depp right that is correct and
you will recall that the video of Mr
Depp in the kitchen was released online
the day before your deposition in August
of 2016. don't you that's correct
you're the one who released that video
isn't that true
that's incorrect I flew in from another
place at the time I remember learning
about it when I landed
so it's just a coincidence that the
video you took of Mr dapp was released
the day before you were to pose in
connection with your divorce for Mr Depp
I absolutely had nothing to do with that
I wouldn't even know how to do something
like that
okay
you settled your divorce for Mr Depp in
August of 2016 right
that sounds right
and in connection with that settlement
he received a seven million dollars from
Mr Depp true that's correct
6.8 exactly
Your settlement amount was seven million
dollars that's correct okay
and then you release a statement in
which you claimed you would be donating
the entire seven million dollars to
charity right that's correct
you stated you would be donating half of
the seven million dollars to the ACLU
that's correct and you would be donating
the other half to Children's Hospital of
Los Angeles that's correct and you also
stated with respect to the seven million
dollar divorce settlement that money
played no role except for the extent
that you could donate the money to
charity
yes that's correct
please pull up plaintiff's exhibit 1259
this is an article entitled Amber Heard
donates Johnny Depp divorce settlement
to charity read her statement in full
is that correct
that's what the title says yes directing
your attention to the portion on the
second page where it says quote read the
statement below
[Music]
is that the statement You released
misheard
that is correct
your honor I move to admit the statement
and the article as redacted objection
hearsay
it's her statement
did this is not her statement this is
some she just testified statement
may I see the full uh everything else is
redacted
um
okay then I have no objection all right
one two five nine and evidence has
redacted
statement reads
as described in the restraining order
and divorce settlement money played no
role for me personally and never has
except to the extent that I could donate
it to charity and in doing so hopefully
help those less able to defend
themselves
as reported in the media the amount
received in the divorce was 7 million
dollars and seven million dollars is
being donated this is over and above any
funds that I have given away in the past
and will continue to give away in the
future
did I read that correctly
that is correct I don't remember that
last line but I have no
it doesn't stand out to me is wrong
there's nothing inaccurate in the
statement not that I recognize no
[Music]
Mr Depp donated a hundred thousand
dollars of the divorce settlement
directly to the ACLU is that right
right at the beginning of the divorce
settlement he donated a hundred thousand
to each charity on my behalf or towards
my contribution so hundred thousand
dollars to each to the ACLU and to the
Children's Hospital
and in response you publicly demanded
that Mr Debt Pay the divorce settlement
directly to you instead of the Charities
right that was always the agreement
actually is for him to pay me directly
it was not his money as per the
settlement agreement to give away and
reap a tax benefit from
I said if he wants to do it and give to
charity all of a sudden then he should
pay
the correct amount and not try to get a
big tax break for it so effectively for
his tax bracket he should be paying
double that amount to the charity
directly and if you wanted to pay the
charity directly he could
he could do that was fine with me but he
would need to pay the adjusted amount
ultimately the rest of the seven million
divorce settlement was paid directly to
you right over time yes Mr dapton and
end up paying the rest of the seven
million divorce settlement directly to
the Charities you identified that is
correct he paid the installments to me
you thought that from happening didn't
you
I don't understand what your question is
I'm sorry you stopped Mr Depp from
paying the Charities that you had named
directly that is incorrect I said if you
want to pay the Charities directly paid
the adjusted amount or pay is per our
agreement in the settlement or in the
divorce
as per our agreement
and he chose to do the former not the
latter I mean the other way around
you also publicly stated that the seven
million dollar divorce settlement should
be paid to the Charities immediately in
full right if he wanted to pay it in the
way that he was suggesting yes
and and you said publicly that the
payments to the Charities should not be
drawn out over many years right
I said that I don't I don't recall the
exact words that I use but basically
that he shouldn't use this as an a novel
interest in getting a tax break that if
he wanted to do that and not pay me the
settlement that was fine but he would
have to pay the adjusted amount and not
make it you know a a commitment he would
not fulfill or try to avoid in some
other way
and that's because you wanted
the entire world to think that you were
donating every penny of a seven million
divorce settlement as soon as he
received it for Mr dupp isn't that right
no I was going to be receiving it in
installments and I would be paying in
installments
the donations
bonds to Mr Depp's hundred thousand
dollar donations to the ACLU and chla
didn't you I don't recall
let's see if we can refresh a
recollection if we could please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit one two six zero
foreign
article entitled Amber Heard and Johnny
Depp row over divorce donations
and if I could direct your attention to
where it says
I believe it's on the second page
her spokeswoman responded in a statement
the language that follows the statement
it's not her right a spokesperson is an
exception in your honor you want to come
forward
foreign
You released a statement through we
approach again okay
before we ask the next question I'll
just hand you a copy of this one
that's why I'm saying okay that's
exactly what I said
thank you
your honor would you like to see one as
well no I that's right that's fine okay
could you please turn your microphone on
I'm sorry
um they gave me a redacted but I don't
have the unredacted to be able to see
the fall I plan to admit it or ask that
it'd be admitted in redacted form I'm
taking away any hearsay and I'm just
trying to lay the foundation but this is
a statement she released through a
spokesperson how would I know whether
there's more to it that shouldn't be
redacted your honor if I don't see the
full document
okay
your honor of the witness can testify as
to whether this is a full statement or
not
the witness can't do we have the right
to be able to see the documentary do you
have a document that's not redacted we
can pull it up on our computers okay
I'll just give us a moment all right
I can represent this is the full
statement that's reported
give an opportunity to look at the
unredactical
thank you
yes
so you're gonna can we have a copy of
this
you can get a copy that uh happily later
later today okay right I mean I I think
she should be giving us copies of the
phone well I understand but we'll take
care of that but okay as of right now
can we continue
but I haven't
okay come forward
all right
so directing your attention Miss heard
where it says her spokeswoman responded
in a statement your language that
follows her again she can't read it she
has to show the language that follows
right if you want to lay a foundation to
that go ahead
You released a statement after Mr Depp
donated a hundred thousand dollars to
the ACLU and a hundred thousand dollars
to chla correct Miss heard I think so
yes okay
and the language that follows is the
statement You released in response to Mr
Depp's donations right
I don't know if this is this the
official statement I really I have no
idea
the semen that reads starts Amber Heard
that's the only thing I'm going to say
would you please read that to yourself
it's hard
yes
did you read all the way to the very
bottom where the last word is supported
yes okay that's the statement You
released through your spokeswoman after
Mr Depp made the donations to the chla
and the ACLU correct Miss heard I do not
recall exactly what my statement was
I don't disagree with anything in the
statement but I just simply don't recall
what the statement was we released is
there anything inaccurate in that
statement no
I'm going to move to admit Jackson
You're on the foundation I'll overruled
the objection one two six zero and
evidence over objection thank you your
honor
statement reads Amber Heard appreciates
Johnny Depp's novel interest in
supporting two of her favorite Charities
the ACLU American civil liberties Union
for domestic violence and the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles
this is great and unexpected news
and it continues
however if Johnny wishes to change the
settlement agreement we must insist that
he honor the full amount by donating 14
million dollars to charity which after
accounting for his tax deduction is
equal to his seven million dollar
payment obligation to Amber
and it continues
we would also insist that the full
amount be paid immediately and not drawn
out over many years anything less would
be a transparent attempt by Johnny's
Council Laura wasser and Patty Glaser to
reduce their clients true payment by
half under the guise of Newfound concern
for Charities that he has never
previously supported end quote
did I read that correctly yes
thank you
after this you kept commenting about the
donation of your divorce settlement
right
uh I don't know what you mean by that
I spoke about donating your divorce
settlement on a Danish TV show correct
uh I believe I said I had
um
I I believe I said I donated it to
charity but it was already printed or
already
commented on and stated in the Press I
had already released that information in
the Press I think I just confirmed it on
that show you appeared on a show called
RTL late night right I don't recall it
which show it was
please play plaintiff's exhibit 346
which is a portion of your appearance on
this program
we would ask that it be moved into
evidence and ask for permission to
publish it it contains it has hearsay it
contains other Communications with other
individuals your honor if we may
approach very briefly
so if we could please play and publish
to the jury plaintiff's exhibit three
four six
three four six inhabitants and actually
were all kinds of accusations uh flying
your way when you said all this and then
there was a divorce settlement you got
seven million dollars people were saying
this is all about the money but then you
did something that uh Twisted that whole
argument what did you do with that money
seven million dollars in total was
donated to I split it between the ACLU
and Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
ACLU is a human rights organization
sorry ACLU is a prominent
um uh organization non-profit
organization in the United States it's
called the American civil liberties
Union and they work on behalf of
marginalized communities uh on the
ground and the legislative reform and
well more power to you because that's
that's something that I've never wanted
nothing
foreign
was in October of 2018 right Miss heard
I don't recall when it was it was in
2018 right Miss heard
I don't remember when this was done
this was after you had received the full
seven million dollars of your divorce
settlement for Mr death wasn't it again
without knowing when it was recorded I
have no idea
seven million divorce settlement was
paid paid to you in full by February of
2018 right that's correct
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
1458 which is already in evidence
this is the deal Point memorandum from
your divorce settlement right Miss heard
yes that's what it looks like
if we go down to the bottom of page four
there's a heading labeled
equalization payment do you see that yes
and underneath that it outlines the
payment schedule for the divorce
payments correct
uh yes well it begins to and if we go on
page
five
so the first payment is scheduled for
August 31st 2016 and that's 200 000
correct yes that is correct
Mr Duff's accountant Edward White
testified that he made that payment
directly
you've got to turn on your microphone Mr
Hoff I am not going to hear you
objection to her testifying to what Mr
White testified to that okay it's that
actual it he literally testified to it
in court follow her rule objection thank
you your honor Mr Duff's accountant
Edward White testified that he made the
payment directly to the ACLU and chla
correct I believe so yes
and then the rest of the payments were
all made to you weren't they that is
correct and the final payment of 2.3
million dollars is on February 1st 2018
right the final payment yes and you were
here in court when Mr White testified
the payments were all made on schedule
I'm an object to her testifying to what
Mr White testified
objection go ahead thank you your honor
and you were here in court when Mr White
testified that the payments were all
made on schedule right
I don't believe they were uh he might
have tested my question Miss heard my
question was you were here in court when
Mr White testified under oath
that all the payments were made on
schedule
I was here every day in court I I heard
his testimony yes okay
so back to October of 2018 this was
before Mr death sued you for deformation
correct
yes that's correct he didn't sue you
until after the op-ed came out in
December of 2018 right he sued me in
2019.
and the op-ed came out in December of
2018. that is correct so in October of
2018 you had received your entire seven
million divorce settlement you agree
with me that is correct okay
now you hadn't yet been sued by Mr dupp
this is uh
October correct
so in this October 2018 interview you
said that you had quote donated
end quote your entire divorce settlement
to charity right that's correct and in
fact your exact words were quote seven
million in total was donated to I split
it between the ACLU and the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles end quote right
that's correct I made that statement as
soon as I got a divorce and we reached
the settlement that's when I pledged it
right then
and you say this because you quote
wanted nothing end quote that is correct
but you hadn't donated your entitled
entire seven million dollars settlement
to charity at that point had you that's
incorrect
sitting here today Miss heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect I pledged the entirety of the
settlements
I intend to fulfill those obligations
that's not my question
please try to answer my question
sitting here today you have not donated
the seven million dollars donated not
pledged donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
I use Pledge and donation synonymous
with one another but I don't think
misheard
I don't use it synonymous
are paid misheard
that's not my question
as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the ACLU yes or no
I have not yet
and as of today you have not paid 3.5
million dollars of your own money to the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
correct I have not yet Johnny sued me so
as of today you have not donated
paid seven million dollars of your
divorce settlement to charity right
I have not been able to fulfill those
those uh obligations yet
and that's because you did want
something
didn't you I didn't want anything and I
didn't get anything you wanted Mr Duff's
money
didn't get it wasn't interested in it I
loved Johnny that's why I was with him
you wanted praise for donating the money
that's incorrect
in general one does want good press yes
you want it to seem altruistic publicly
wasn't my interest my interest is uh in
my name and clearing my name and at the
time I was being called a liar and my
motives were being questioned I did see
it as important to
clear that up I wanted to make a
statement to make sure that there was
not any doubt that I couldn't be labeled
these things just because Johnny was a
bigger star and had more publicity reach
remind every one of your claims of
domestic violence against Mr Depp right
no I wanted to move on with my life you
wanted to make those claims seem
believable
they are believable they wanted them to
be seen you wanted to be seen excuse me
as a noble victim of domestic violence I
have to never never wanted to be seen as
a victim
nor have I ever called myself one
you testified under oath that quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote didn't you
that's correct I pledged the entirety
no
misheard
my questions
your Council will have time to redirect
you
after
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement was
donated
to charity end quote that is correct I
pledged the entirety
to strike everything after yes
are
okay
now
Miss hurt is this really inappropriate
I'll sustain the objection and we'll
just move forward let's move forward
next question
under oath that statement wasn't true
was it misheard
I'm sorry I don't follow your question
sorry
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of my divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote that
statement wasn't true
it is true I pledged the entirety to
charity
statement when you say you buy a house
you don't pay the entire house exactly
you pay another time all right next
question please thank you
that statement isn't true today as you
sit here today is it
it is true I pledged the entirety but
you didn't donate it
unfortunately you didn't donate it it's
a yes or no I haven't been able to
obligate I mean to fulfill those so
that's a no right Miss heard I am I made
the pledge I want to be very clear I
pledge the entirety I haven't been able
to fulfill those pledges because I've
been sued you had all of the seven
million dollars for 13 months before Mr
Depp sued you and you chose not to pay
it to the Charities you pledged it to is
that correct I disagree with your
characterization of that
let's look at your sworn testimony from
the UK
all right yes ma'am
thank you
Miss Vasquez do you want me to close the
shades
there's this light coming across them so
I appreciate them
thank you for your honor all right
this is uh your third witness statement
that you submitted in the UK action
right Miss heard correct and this
statement was made under oath true that
is true I'm directing your attention to
the last page
of that statement
that's your signature right
yes it is so you made the sworn
statement on February 26 2000
2020.
that's correct
and directing your attention to
paragraph four
it says
quote I remained financially independent
from him the whole time we were together
and the entire amount of my divorce
settlement was donated to charity end
quote that is correct did I read that
correctly yes you did the hymn you were
referring to is Mr dupp that is correct
the money that was donated to the ACLU
and chla and your name came from someone
else isn't that right
I don't know what you mean by most stuff
well at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the ACLU and
your name wasn't paid by you right uh I
believe Elon made a donation in my honor
on one of one of the years yeah and it
didn't come out of your seven million
dollar divorce settlement right no nor
did it count towards my pledge
and at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles and
your name wasn't paid by you either
right those were made at the same time
and it didn't come out of your seven
million dollar divorce settlement nor
did it count to why
3.5 obligation those five hundred
thousand dollar payments came from your
new boyfriend Elon Musk right
uh he I don't know if he was a new
boyfriend at the time
you got him to pay part of what you
promised to these two Charities didn't
you incorrect because you wanted to keep
at least some of the seven million
divorce settlement for yourself right
I'm very wrong about that
I think this if you're honors this is a
good stuff Breaking Point okay that's
fine all right ladies and gentlemen
we'll stop here for the evening remember
tonight do not do any outside research
and do not discuss the case with anybody
I know these days are a little longer
and I appreciate your patient patience
and and you're taking care of everything
here please take care of yourself
tonight okay and we'll see in the
morning at 9am
friends
foreign
testimony with anybody to include your
attorneys okay all right nine o'clock
tomorrow then all right we'll see you at
9 o'clock thank you
all right